To one phone number live.
First of all,
cheers gentlemen.
Let's have a little bit of toast.
Relax.
Bob,
thank you very much for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I understand that you've told the story many,
many times.
You've been grilled many,
many times and it's very stressful for you.
So I've,
I really,
really appreciate your time.
For people who don't know the story,
um,
there is a documentary,
Jeremy Cor,
bell has a documentary out right now.
It's called Bob Lasar area 51 and Ufos and flying saucers and flying saucers,
not 51 and fly.
It's okay.
Um,
I first heard your story decades go,
I've uh,
I told you last night we went out to dinner.
I've seen pretty much every interview you've ever given.
I've followed the story incredibly closely,
but for people who don't know the story,
let's give them the bullet points.
You used to work at area 51 and area 51.
Got You.
You went like,
Huh?
Well,
you know,
we want to be accurate.
Okay.
Area as for s four,
it's about 15 miles south of area 51.
Okay.
But,
um,
you worked in,
what would do,
how would you describe it?
I guess within the area 51 compound,
you can call that a subset of area 51.
And yes.
You got that job.
Before that you were working,
before that I had worked at Los Alamos national labs in New Mexico
and you were involved in
what kind of work?
The nuclear weapon development physics.
I mean that's,
they do everything there.
So how do they approach you to say,
Hey Bob,
why don't you come on out to the Nevada
desert?
Well,
the way this went down was,
um,
at that time it was 1982,
I,
um,
I put,
uh,
a jet engine in my,
my Honda and Los Alamos put it on the front page of the paper.
He said,
you know,
uh,
Los Alamos man physicist at the lab,
you know,
built this 200 mile an hour,
on the jet card that I drove to work every day.
So,
uh,
so I was known in Los Alamos,
the guy with the weird car and you know,
you could hear it from,
you know,
a mile away.
Anyway,
the day that came out on the front page of the paper was the day Edward Teller,
the father of the hydrogen bomb was giving a lecture down there at the lab and
we didn't have much going on that day in our group.
And I asked if I could go down there.
And,
um,
I went down there early and ed teller was outside leaning on a brick wall there
and reading the front page of the paper.
Now this the guy out of history.
So I introduced myself,
Hey,
I'm the guy you're reading about there.
And we talked for a little while and it was cool.
Uh,
you know,
fast forward two years later I had moved out to Las Vegas and had,
left Los Alamos and,
you know,
went on to other things and I wanted to get back into the scientific community.
Yeah.
I left start other businesses and,
and that sort of thing.
So I sent resumes out and one of them went out to ed teller and referenced our
meeting,
you know,
back back in the day.
And,
uh,
anyway,
he remembered me and gave me a reference,
somebody to contacted Eg and g.
And that's pretty much how it started.
So
you get a phone call or a letter,
like what do you get?
Well,
I got a,
what did I get?
I got a letter initially and went down for an interview probably a couple times
and it was down at,
uh,
Eg and g special projects,
which was,
um,
at McCarran airport at that time out in Las Vegas.
And did they give you any sort of job description of what you were applying for?
Um,
they said it was for,
I can't remember exactly what they did.
This was a long time ago,
but I think it was,
um,
advanced propulsion or something like that.
Something relatively generic.
And they said it's in a remote area.
Um,
you know,
it's going to be some days on,
some days off.
And um,
you know,
it was kind of a,
not exactly a full time job,
but you might have to be out there for two weeks at a time and take two weeks
off.
So it was kind of,
uh,
the work schedule would be kind of broken up.
And did they seem attractive to you or did it seem weird?
Wehrly wasn't,
yeah.
Where'd,
because people that work at the test site,
anybody that's familiar with the area up there,
um,
you know,
working at the nuclear test site,
uh,
or at the tone of pod test range north of there,
that's typically how things go.
So you had known about it from the scientific community because the area 51 at
that time was anything about area 51 okay.
So they just said it was in,
uh,
you know,
in a remote location and you just know it was up at the test site.
Right.
So,
but there was no mention of area 51 at that time.
So they've done hundreds of nuclear tests in Nevada,
in Nevada that that whole area was,
there's been just giant chunks of Nevada that people,
yeah,
there's a
big piece of Nevada and it's split up into different areas.
There's a nuclear test site,
there's area 51 there's the tone of pod test range north of that.
There's little sub areas.
There's areas where they test chemical weapons and things like that.
So it's all broken up as a gigantic test area.
So take me back to first day on the job,
you accepted job,
they take you out there.
Yeah,
it's um,
the first day really I didn't really get to see a whole lot.
The first day was essentially just paperwork.
That's when I flew into area 51 proper and I left a McCarran airport and flew
what they call the Janet flights.
Just,
um,
you know,
a passenger plane from Las Vegas to area 51,
and it was really just going through a mountain of paperwork that day,
uh,
from security clearances to,
um,
God.
There was,
it was like two or three hours of just solid paperwork and that was,
that was really an uneventful first day.
When did things get weird?
When did you realize that at what point in time did you say,
Hey,
this is not normal work?
Like this doesn't even seem like it's from this planet?
Yeah.
That,
I can't tell you what day that occurred on because so much time has gone by the
days of kind of fused into one and I can't separate the days.
Was it a slow burn or was there a moment of recognition?
Well,
they're the,
the first inkling I had was when I,
I came in normal.
There's this facility that is at s four.
It's in the side of a mountain.
And normally we had pulled in with the bus and gone around the front through a
normal double door.
Yeah.
This time that I went in there were hangar doors open.
I went into the hangar door and in the hangar door was the disc,
the flying saucer that I worked on.
I saw it sitting there and we walked by it.
It had a little American flag stuck on the side and I thought,
oh my God,
this finally explains all the flying saucer stories.
This is just an advanced fighter and it,
this is fucking hilarious,
right?
So I went by,
I slid my hand alongside it.
I got reprimanded immediately for touching the thing.
And,
uh,
there was a guy in armed guard that followed it's in and just said,
keep your eyes at forward in your hands at your site and just walk in the door.
So that was the first time I'd seen anything.
That was weird.
It was some time later that I was introduced to my,
um,
my lab partner Barry and we had some of the sub components of the craft,
uh,
in the lab and Barry was very anxious to get a new lab partner.
So he was very talkative and couldn't wait to show me different things.
And it was in the demonstration of the reactor working where it caught my
attention to where this is technology that doesn't even exist.
So I mean that was the first time I knew that this is
really something different.
What was it,
what was it?
What was the,
what was it about this reactor that made you think that it didn't exist
technologically?
Well it was that I actually have to back up cause there were some briefings that
I read it before that,
that
um,
you know,
certainly gave me the impression that this is going to be a weird job.
But this was the first hands on thing.
Uh,
this was a small reactor about the size of a hemisphere,
about the size of a basketball on a metal plate.
And when was running it produced a gravitational field,
the gravitational field of its own.
Now this is something that we can't do.
We can't produce any gravity.
The only way we get gravity is from large quantities of mass.
But there's no machine we can have that turns on that makes gravity like,
uh,
you know,
you can turn on an electromagnet and it makes a magnetic field.
We can't make a gravitational field.
Anyway,
this device was producing that and Barry said,
almost like he was bragging.
Go ahead and try and try and touch the sphere.
And I,
I couldn't,
it would,
it pushed my hands away.
Just like two light poles of a magnet.
So that was a,
so like when you take two magnets and trying to press them together and then
yeah,
you have this,
each other,
yeah.
That kinda could cushion feeling,
but you can't,
you can't get them together.
The closer you put them,
the more they push button.
You felt that physical with my hand.
Yeah.
Now there's nothing,
there's nothing that does that.
And that immediately caught my attention going,
wow,
this is something else.
What was your thought like when you felt that and you knew that there was
nothing that you're aware of that could pretend that that connected me to the
briefings that I read on the first day at s four was that,
uh,
you know,
everything that I had read was apparently accurate.
What were you reading?
I read,
it was kind of an overview.
This project was to back engineer the alien craft and specifically it was to try
and back engineer and see if we can duplicate the technology with available
materials.
Now to do this,
they split the project into,
you know,
many different pieces for several reasons.
They do,
they do this on all classified projects.
So,
uh,
nobody has the complete story,
but,
uh,
they compartmentalize everything.
Now we have the power and propulsion system.
So what have briefings they gave me were like a one or two page overview of some
of the other projects that were going on,
you know,
on the craft.
The only reason they do that is just in case what you're working on is connected
intimately in some way that we don't know up to one of the other projects.
You have to know their,
excuse me,
their existence.
So,
um,
you know,
I,
but again,
everything from metallurgy to um,
you know,
weapon,
potential,
the craft and these were all,
you know,
essentially very short briefings,
but mine was just power and propulsion and it made it very clear that what I
read was accurate.
So when you're reading that,
before you actually saw the reactor,
what were your thoughts on what they were describing?
If you knew that something like that didn't exist and they're describing it and
the briefings,
what did you think you're going to see?
I really,
I,
I didn't know at the time.
I mean,
I was reading,
I thought,
is this some kind of test?
Um,
see if you're crazy.
Well,
not to see if I'm crazy to,
uh,
you know,
a lot of times they'll take an real high security,
uh,
jobs.
I mean,
they'll intentionally insert nonsense into them.
Um,
whether it's to confuse the fact or if for someone was to leak it out,
uh,
they would carry that information along and know where it came from.
So I read through the documents,
but you know,
I didn't know if this was,
you know,
part of some kind of test or,
um,
you know,
or,
or what,
or was it potentially realistic?
I mean,
I had really didn't consider it being all that possible as far as being,
uh,
the actual thing that I was going to work on at the time.
How did they turn it on there?
The reactor?
Yeah.
You react.
It can be turned on or turned off in a lot of different ways.
Um,
the way Barry showed me at the hemisphere is removed.
There was a small tower in the middle.
When you put the hemisphere on,
the reactor activates,
the reactors,
shuts down.
It's,
it's load sensing.
So if there's,
if there's no load on the reactor at all,
it shuts down.
When there's a load present on it,
it starts up again load meaning you can get centered in electrical load.
So although it doesn't necessarily operate electrically,
there's no wiring that connects any of the sub components together whatsoever.
They just have to be in the immediate vicinity.
It's a,
it is,
but the stuff is borderline magic and that's essentially where we left it,
you know,
when I left the project,
so there was no progress made.
There was some progress.
I mean,
we did identify,
at least we think some processes and,
and had a rough idea.
We think of what was going on.
But,
um,
I think this is a problem that they've had for a long time.
And,
um,
you know,
the,
I was replacing somebody that Barry worked with prior to me and I think there
was some horrific accident that I didn't have a whole lot of information on.
But you know,
Barry alluded to that horrific accident.
What,
where someone died or yeah,
where somebody died because they were trying to tamper with things or figure out
how something worked.
Yeah.
The reactor in particular,
but yet he let you touch it.
Yeah.
I think what they were trying to do was cut into one now they had,
they had more than one there and that was supposedly there was an unannounced
nuclear test and that's what it was at the time.
Remember they was still do an underground nuclear tests at the test site.
Um,
but from what I understand,
according to Barry,
there was an attempt made.
Now this must've been a pretty desperate attempt because it's not very
scientific process to cut,
you know,
analyze something that way.
But it looked like they used a plasma cutter or something.
I got to cut into an operating reactor.
How many of these things did they have?
They had nine,
nine craft altogether.
I only got hands on with one of them.
So I can't really say what the,
you know,
how the others operated?
Did you see the other ones?
Yeah.
At one time.
And only one time,
the bay doors between the hangers were all open and I could see all the way
through.
And were they all exactly the same?
No,
they were all different.
Different shapes.
Yeah,
but they were all from somewhere else.
absolutely.
Now,
did anyone make any attempt to explain or to tell you where they came from?
No.
No one is the least bit interested in letting everybody know all the facts that
they wanted to give you the minimum information that's necessary to complete
your task so you're not getting the story of where they came from.
You're not getting the story of what,
how much progress other people who are making you just focus on the small
component,
but they gave you some indication that they'd been working on these for awhile.
Yeah.
When do you think they acquired these?
I really couldn't say.
I think they've been around for awhile.
So they bring you into this room,
you see this reactor working you,
you realize this is nothing that as far as like the scientific community at that
current time has the ability to create
[inaudible].
What is your life like from that moment on?
Is that where everything changes?
Cause you do you,
I mean,
I would imagine the moment you actually make contact with something that's extra
terrestrial,
whether it's an object or a being something where you can actually absolutely be
certain.
It's not from here.
You're whole paradigm.
The whole world you live in is now a different place.
This is the only time it became exciting,
you know,
the rest of the time though,
it was really an,
an ominous feeling being at work.
But at that time it was exciting.
I mean,
this was,
now I knew we were on the absolute bi actually beyond the cutting edge of
science.
And I was,
I was so absolutely excited to be there every single time.
I was,
um,
you know,
it,
this was a fantastic opportunity.
And um,
however,
in,
in short order it began to concern me,
we really have no idea what we're talking about.
And the excitement kind of turned to dread at some point because the amount of
power we're dealing with is astronomical.
I mean to affect gravity,
to produce the effects like this equipment does,
takes huge amounts of power.
And I've given the example before of you know,
taking a small portable nuclear reactor and you know,
putting it back into Victorian Times,
you know,
with the scientists at the time and just dropping it or in a room and they come
and look at it and see that it's producing power and wonder how it works at.
They start taking it apart and as soon as they,
some of the shielding off,
the people are going to drop dead because of the radiation inside.
Now the people have no idea that he radiation even exist back then,
but anybody that comes in to check on them,
we'll also drop dead.
And you know,
there's no reason that that exact scenario couldn't happen with what we're
dealing with.
We have no idea how the physics operate within this thing.
The power levels are,
are,
like I said,
astronomic like it's incredibly dangerous to tinker with something like that.
And you know,
in some respects we were Guinea pigs just try to find out how to make this
thing.
So they had had a series e as far as you surmised that a series of different
scientists try to back engineer this thing,
try to figure out what this thing was and they would bring in new people and
like let's throw Bob at it.
Yeah.
And they know,
I don't know how many,
but I knew there was certainly one before me and I knew he died during the
analysis of the or the reactor itself and
you don't know how many have worked on it and no one gave any good,
been there for 50 years.
It could have been there
five years.
Instructions.
What are they saying?
Like w when they're giving you direction,
the showing you all this stuff.
Like what,
what are,
what are they saying specifically?
What are they asking of you?
Well essentially what they ask is,
is what I said we are just to gather as much information as possible,
find out how it operates and see if we can duplicate it.
So I was relieved
where it was from.
They never let you ask questions about where it's from.
Well if the information I read in the briefings was accurate,
now what I do have to say is the information that pertained directly to the
reactor was accurate.
What I read
did,
I mean did jive with reality.
Um,
in terms of how,
in terms of how it was made,
how,
what we saw,
how it operated,
the materials,
how it,
you know,
turned on and what was discovered,
uh,
discovered about it.
I'm sorry,
the Migraine is really making it hard for me to think here.
We talked about before the podcast should tell everybody Bob was getting a
migraine.
I know you're very stressed out by this.
Was,
is one of the reasons why I appreciate you doing this.
Um,
where was,
I already explained it and uh,
so there was some paperwork that indicated that this was from the Zeta Reticuli
star system now.
Yeah.
Now how they obtain that,
I haven't,
I haven't the slightest idea,
but it wasn't just from the Zeta Reticuli star system.
It was what they calledZ r three.
So it was a third planet in that star system.
So there was no other information about it other than that supposedly whether
craft came from now,
is that true?
I don't know.
I have no way of verifying that.
But that was printed in the same materials that referenced the reactor.
Now I looked that stuff up when I went home and uh,
Zeta,
particularly as a binary star,
um,
two stars that orbit orbit one another and it's only visible in the southern
hemisphere and it's about 30 some odd light years away.
So that's literally all the information I have about that.
I don't know how they found out it came from there.
And you also probably have some suspicions that they give you some
disinformation like you were talking about before where they would,
yeah,
too.
I mean,
if you ever decided to talk about this,
they added a bunch of nonsense to make whatever is factual look ridiculous.
Right.
Or be able to trace it down like,
hey,
this fax came out and you know,
this Lasar guy said at cat,
you know,
came from Zeta Reticuli so they knew who it was.
Would it be made bread?
Zeta reticulate we like,
what in the fuck is this?
Well,
reading all of this stuff,
it was,
what in the fuck is this?
Like why did I sign up for this week?
To me this was cool.
This was interesting.
I said I was just excited to be out in a secure area,
you know,
in the middle of the desert.
I said,
this is awesome.
How old are you going on?
I guess as in my twenties
yeah,
so you'd probably like totally geeked out.
Oh yeah,
this was,
this was great.
I mean,
I was excited so I didn't care.
I reading through everything.
And
so you read through all the Zeta particularly thing,
but then when you see the actual star ship with the little American flag sticker
on it,
well that was,
was that later or before
that?
That was before.
So before.
So you see the thing before and you say,
Oh,
this is the way it was that before hard.
So many years.
Yeah.
I can't either way.
It doesn't matter.
The days of fused together,
it's so hard to separate what happened in eighth visit.
[inaudible] the thought process when you read that it's from zero typically.
Yeah,
it,
it didn't hit me like a ton of bricks or anything.
It's just like,
yeah.
Okay.
And I think it was bullshit.
I don't know.
It's just weird now.
I don't,
I mean,
because when I read it,
I hadn't verified anything and this was just a bunch of stuff I was reading and
I thought maybe after this they're just going to give me a test and see what I
can remember and crazy information and then it would,
but um,
like I said,
when I finally went in with Barry,
um,
and had hands on experience with what they were talking about,
it dot gone a completely different meaning.
So there's a plate,
there's this thing that looks like a half a basketball and when it's on,
you can't come anywhere near it.
You can't touch it.
Right.
How is,
what is gravity about that?
Like the I,
the concept of gravity in most people's gravity's bringing something yeah.
Towards it.
Right.
Well,
I guess you would say it's anti gravity.
It's gravity shifted 180 degrees.
It's a,
you know,
anti gravity.
And did they have any understanding about what could possibly create this
effect?
Did they have any areas where they'd like you to look into?
No,
they,
yeah.
Well they knew there was a fuel source in it and they were proficient at making
it work.
And again,
my analogy to something like this,
as you can drop on motorcycle off in the wagon train days and just leave it with
the keys parked outside,
you know,
somebody's place,
everybody,
I'll come around it and they'll poke and prod and eventually they'll turn the
key,
get it to start and become proficient at writing it.
Yeah.
But they won't be able to understand what the hell is going on.
They won't be able to make the plastic fender much less anything else.
And I think that's exactly the state we were at.
We played around with the parts long enough before I got there where they could
make the reactor operate.
Um,
take the fuel out and know that it makes it work.
how exactly what was going on,
uh,
in the reactor,
a marine main of mystery at the time.
Um,
I think we made some progress on what was going on inside,
but I don't think anybody really knew anything.
They could just watch what was going on and make note of it.
How long were you there?
I'd say about six months or so.
And what progress was made while you were there?
Well,
we came up with a bunch of,
yeah,
reasonably good ideas about how the reactor worked.
And one of them was the base,
the square base of it was essentially like a cyclotron,
which is a small particle accelerator,
a circular one.
Particle accelerators of Linear Particle accelerators are just,
uh,
you know,
long tube essentially in the accelerate particles with high voltage and you
know,
radio frequencies until they reach high speeds.
But a cyclotron does that and a smaller circular area.
And there's this very heavy element fuel element one 15 something that wasn't on
our periodic charts at the time,
but it is now.
It is now.
Yeah.
When did it become on the periodic table now?
The way the charts now,
you know,
I don't remember.
Do you remember when they,
uh,
2004 Darmstadt Germany I think is where they first fabricated for atoms that
lasted 220 milliseconds.
The items,
it's nothing.
Right.
And then it later was discovered a couple more times.
They could fabricate it then they gave it,
they gave it a place then on the periodic chart after that called the Muskogee.
Liam.
So they told you about this stuff in 1982?
Yeah.
Well we can automate it to what,
what year was this?
It was 88,
88 and 89 when I was there.
[inaudible] 82 [inaudible] 82 was when you were at Los Alamos.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
So 88 89 they told you about this stuff.
So this was not like,
no,
they didn't,
they didn't tell me about it.
That's one of the things that this group came up with the um,
um,
I keep losing my train of thought with this thing.
So this one area,
this,
this element one 15 was the fuel.
Yeah,
it was the fuel.
Um,
the,
the world were,
forgive you for having a migraine.
I could,
I guess it's really hard to
give you more.
Yeah,
definitely.
As I say,
one thing,
you know,
bought for the last 30 years,
people have just been on the attack on Bob,
you know,
getting to know him,
the personal effects on his life.
It's really hard to understand unless you meet his family and his wife.
I mean,
this is the last thing he wanted to fucking do was have to talk.
Yeah.
We should explain that.
Jeremy,
you and I had this conversation.
I watched your documentary.
We had this conversation and I said,
I have to talk to them.
Yeah.
The document there was,
there's been detractors,
there's been a bunch of people that called bullshit on many of the things that
you've said,
but over time,
many of the things that you talked about,
even in the 80s,
have proven to be true.
Things that people said were not true.
We're proven to be true.
Element one 15 was one of them.
Right,
right,
right.
Uh,
element one 15,
the fuel they had was stable.
In other words,
it didn't decay.
It wasn't a meeting radioactivity.
Um,
when they synthesized the two or three atoms of the one 15,
uh,
it did decay and it was not a stable element.
So they're,
they're kind of two different things,
but this is kind of typical elements,
always have,
are pretty much always have a stable isotopes and unstable isotopes.
Like I think cesium as like 30 on stable isotopes to it.
So,
all right,
well,
hydrogen for example,
you're familiar with hydrogen gas.
Um,
it's stable.
It's not radioactive,
but there's also two other types of hydrogen,
deuterium and tritium.
And Deuterium isn't radioactive.
It's another stable isotope of hydrogen,
but Tridium is radioactive now.
They're all hydrogen,
but they just have a different amounts of neutrons.
So it's the same thing with other elements and element one 15,
depending on the amount of neutrons it has,
uh,
designates the isotope.
But it's one 15,
they will continue to take,
uh,
or experiment and try and make one 15 at different isotopes.
And I'm sure eventually they'll come up with a stable version,
but it's the taste stable version that has the properties that we're talking
about.
So they somehow or another had acquired a stable version.
Did they say that the stable version had come with this craft?
Right,
absolutely.
Came with the graph.
Yeah.
So at the time you having a firm knowledge of the periodic chart and knowing
what was real and what wasn't real,
what was your reaction to having this stable element one 15 that wasn't even
supposed to exist?
Well,
everything was impossible,
right?
I mean down,
down to the metal.
I did get a chance to look inside the craft on only one occasion.
And this was important because,
um,
where are the reactors?
Sat might have been critical to how it operated since everything operates
without any inner connections.
So the placement of components might be critical.
So they allowed me to go inside and,
and look at it.
Um,
sure.
Again,
I forgot where the hell I am.
So you're going into this craft and what are you thinking when you were inside
of it?
Like what are you seeing?
It's um,
it's a very ominous feeling because it's,
there are no f,
first of all,
everything is one color.
It's like a dark pewter color.
And there are no right angles anywhere.
It's as if somebody took a,
I've said this before,
somebody took on a model out of and fashioned it out of wax and then he did it
just for a short time.
So everything melted.
Everything looks like it's fused together.
Everything has a radius of curvature or to,
uh,
items,
meat.
It's a,
it's a really weird looking thing.
But,
um,
uh,
there was almost nothing other than a small foldable hatchway that,
um,
that looked recognizable.
Everything was,
uh,
was really unworldly to pick on it.
A way to describe it.
So you,
you get inside this thing and it's designed for something that's much smaller
than a human being.
Yeah.
You can't really stand up till you get to the very center of.
And how tall are you?
I'm five.
10.
And what do you think this was designed for?
I'd say something close to half my height.
Wow.
So these little three foot tall ish creatures.
Yeah.
And that the seats were small too.
I mean,
obviously it was made,
you know,
for something,
something small,
but there is no,
like,
there's,
there's nothing else in there.
There's just seats,
the reactor and some of the sub components.
There's no,
there's no control panels.
There's no bathroom.
There's no,
no decorative,
uh,
components or artwork or anything that you would recognize or trim.
I'm in.
It's just a very bare bones thing.
You're not seeing any screens.
Well,
there are archways around it at that are part of the superstructure and that one
of the archways can become a transparent,
when I was in there,
there was another group working on one of the archways and you could call that a
screen
more or less.
So through that archway it would be,
it would maintain the solidity,
the,
the solid,
whatever metal it was.
Yeah.
But you could sit.
Just became transparent.
Yeah.
I saw that happen once or twice before I left.
Did you ask any questions about what the no,
there's no asking because no one's asking the question now,
but when you watch something become transparent and you realize it's still
there,
but you can now see through it.
Yeah.
I mean now that's not that impressive.
We do have some liquid crystal materials that are like that,
you know,
they never seen in smart glass.
Yeah.
They call it smart glass.
So this is just a,
and I don't know if the craft is made of,
you know,
in advance metal or a ceramic.
It was cold to the church.
So,
um,
you know,
I would lean more towards a metal.
You're not allowed to ask questions.
No,
the only,
they work on the buddy system so I can only exchange ideas and talk to Barry.
Now this really interferes with science because science is based on free
discussion and ideally you get a bunch of guys together,
exchange ideas,
work on problems and that's how things move forward.
But they're so over the top concerned about security.
They split everything off and everybody becomes stagnant.
It,
it,
it just destroys any of the progress you can make or at least makes it go so
slow.
Um,
they,
I think they wound up shooting themselves in the foot,
which is probably why they are arrived at this bottleneck that they need to get
this madman with a jet powered Honda come in and see what he could do.
I think that was an act of desperation.
I think they wanted someone that's thinks out of the box and let's,
let's just give this guy a try here because they weren't,
and they might've done this four more times since uh,
you know,
up to the point in time today,
assuming they're still working on this thing.
And
when you see this craft and you're inside,
was there any indication that there was an area that they would use to control
it?
The pilot was there,
a pilot seat was theirs.
There were three seats.
They sat around.
Uh,
the reactor was in the dead center of it and then equidistant around.
There were three seats and that's all there.
There was a,
a large,
you would,
they're not consoles.
There are large rectangular objects also spaced equidistant around the center.
Um,
there's nothing on them.
There's no buttons,
there's no lights.
There's,
and they look the same color,
the same,
everything is the same color,
different shape,
right.
And,
um,
directly underneath them there's three levels in the craft.
Uh,
the main level is what we're talking about directly under that.
Those are the gravity amplifiers,
the big rectangular objects underneath them are the gravity of mentors that look
like,
for lack of a better word,
a trashcan hanging on a pipe,
three of those.
And then the top layer,
I,
this is just my personal belief,
I think that has to do with that,
uh,
navigation or their version of a computer,
with some planar panels,
sensor panels around the craft that we would call port holes,
but they're not portals,
they're just black areas.
And I think that just determines its position in space.
But I was,
I physically was in the center section and I stuck my torso in the bottom
section and hung upside down so I could see how the gravity amplifiers were
positioned.
What is the,
the roughly the size of this thing?
It's a,
I think it,
I don't remember from being there,
but,
um,
after all this stuff was over,
I had a John Andrews,
a guy from the testers model corporation and you know,
we sat down and tried to figure out from what I saw,
um,
and known sizes of things and we came up with 52 feet in diameter.
And I think that's a small,
yeah.
So I think that's a fair reasonable guess.
Now you said there's nine of them and you got a brief glimpse at the other ones
were the,
how were they different?
Oh,
they looked completely different.
One looked like a,
I called a Jello mold and it,
it looked like a classic Jello mold with a rippled sides to it.
One was a very flat disk.
Um,
you know,
like,
uh,
oh,
I don't like a straw hat or something like that that was sitting up on its edge.
And the thin part of it had,
it looked like a projectile had been fired through,
um,
the edge of it.
So I don't know if they were attempting to see if the metal could be penetrated
or if something or if that's where the thing came from.
Maybe it was shot down.
Um,
but that was the only one where I saw there was,
you know,
actual physical damage
and that one was roughly the same size.
They're all,
yeah,
they were kind of too far away to,
to tell
and did.
There was several teams that we're working on the propulsion systems,
there's different teams that were work on these different aircraft.
I,
I don't don't know.
I could only assume right now when you're sitting in this thing and you're
looking at this other worldly craft,
your,
your goal is to try to figure out how this thing functions,
your goals to try to figure out how this reactor it,
I mean,
it would imagine they would give you more time than just one day to check that
out.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't one day,
right?
Yeah.
I mean this is,
Barry was there,
I think Barry was sleeping there.
I'm sure they had.
Now that that isn't weird.
I mean up at the tone of Pod test range where they work on stealth fighters,
you know,
you go I think three weeks on one week off and you stay up there too.
So it's not weird to stay up at the test site.
Right.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think he pretty,
anyway,
that didn't mean he acted like he's been up there for a long time.
Um,
but I'm still there.
Yeah,
we knows you.
Do you do you have contact with this guy?
No.
Oh No.
I wish I did.
I kind of thought he was gonna come out after I did and I think I took so much
flak and it's so much shit for what went on.
I think I actually,
I wound up helping security there and everybody became afraid of doing or saying
anything after that.
So what kind of reports did you have to give?
Like,
so you're not making much progress,
right?
You're just trying to figure out what this thing is and it seems impossible.
Well,
we didn't personally make them.
I mean we were always,
there was never a lot of information that we gained.
Um,
the,
you would call them,
our supervisor was,
the name was Dennis Mariani and kind of a military looking guy.
And he would routinely pop in,
you know,
during the day and you know,
hey,
what's going on guys?
And he would essentially relay,
enter any information,
anything new we came up with.
I mean,
he was our go between where we presented him the information.
Then he took it to wherever they were,
you know,
assembling all the data from everybody.
No,
I assume you're working normal days,
like you need an hour day.
No,
no,
no.
It was really weird that I would be only called in on certain times on certain
days and they would be weird hours too.
Most of the time was later in the evening.
I mean,
I can get a call at 11 o'clock at night and they'll say,
you know,
it's now 11 o'clock,
um,
by 1145 you need to be at McCarran terminal.
And,
um,
you know,
we'll let you know and uh,
we have more information.
But what did you do while you were there?
If you're looking at this object,
this reactor,
and you can't figure out what it is or how it works other than the fact that
works on this element that we don't even know about it.
Sure.
I mean,
the thing was to what you do and you know,
with anything,
if you're trying to analyze it,
all you can do is perform a test.
And all we did is try and come up with every kind of test we possibly could.
I man,
we tested,
you know,
it violated a lot of what we thought was impossible to violate.
I mean,
one of the first laws of thermodynamics,
I mean essentially any machine,
any device that operates always makes extra heat.
Nothing works at a 100% efficient.
Even the headphones you're wearing,
anything that takes power,
some of that power is going to be con converted to heat and it's just wasted.
This didn't,
I mean we looked at,
back then we had infrared cameras.
There are different today,
but back then you had a poor liquid nitrogen into the camera to cool the sensor
down and um,
and get these infrared images you've seen.
But it never got,
no matter what the load was on the reactor,
it never got above the ambient temperature,
which is impossible.
I mean,
you're,
you know,
pulling out huge amounts of power and nothing ever gets warm.
Um,
we tried measuring magnetic fields and there was,
was nothing there.
So we started playing around with the,
uh,
emission from the emitter is the gravity wave itself and saw what we could do
with it and how it was focused.
So we really spent all our time just trying to see what the stuff can do and
what we can control.
So you were seeing what it could do,
would you couldn't ever figure out how it was doing it?
No,
not really.
I mean,
we really,
we really could only use,
uh,
come up with a best guests.
And now I can't say we high that I could absolutely state for certainly are
certainty how anything actually worked.
Now,
how did you know at all how they were piloting it?
Because some,
they were doing some tests where they're having these things fly around in the
sky and this is what gets us deeper into your story.
Right.
Um,
I was out there for a one test.
right.
In fact,
I was in with Barry in the lab and Dennis came in and said,
uh,
we're about to run a test.
Why don't you guys come out?
Or He's,
I think he said,
Barry,
why don't you come out here and bring Bob with you?
Uh,
we went out there and the craft was already outside the hangar and was just
preparing to lift off.
Now they were in communication with somebody in the craft.
So there's a person in the present.
Yeah,
there was certainly a person in there.
Now it's not a comfortable place to be in cause it's small.
So the guy has to be sitting on the floor in the middle.
Uh,
my best guess,
and this is the same specific craft that you cause you were the,
that was the only craft that you weren't the only one that I touched and worked
on.
Um,
and it,
it quietly lifted off the ground,
which was incredibly impressive to see a quietly or silently what's well quietly
because it did it make sure it reduced.
Um,
a little corona discharge from the bottom at corona discharge is kind of a high
voltage brush,
little bluish glow discharge.
As it was lifting off the ground.
You can hear a slight his sound now as soon as it cleared the ground by about
five or 10 feet,
maybe even less than that,
the hissing stopped and the blue go disappeared.
So it lifted off quietly and then it hovered silently if you want to be
specific.
Wow.
So then what kind of maneuvers was doing?
It took off for that particular time.
It took off,
moved a little round around to the left and right and then sat back down.
The,
um,
the craft itself.
MMM.
They communicated with it with a wreck because I saw the guy talking,
uh,
and a regular VHF radio to the person in the craft,
and I even saw the frequency that was on the,
the frequency counter or the,
uh,
communication,
the transceiver there.
Um,
but what's weird is he shouldn't be able to communicate with the craft,
with a radio.
The radio,
the radio wave should bend around the craft.
I mean,
it,
it shouldn't be possible at every single thing about these,
the craft and the way they operated didn't make any sense to us.
I mean,
that's something we talked about for awhile after.
Why should the frequency bend around the craft?
Well,
you really have to look at the way the gravity wave comes out of the craft as a,
the reactors in the center and there's a wave guide that goes up to the top.
There's actually a small appendage that sticks out at the top of the craft and
it produces a heart shaped gravitational distortion around the craft.
Now if the craft is sitting in the air and you walk underneath it and look up,
you actually cannot see the craft,
the light bends around it.
You're bending,
gravity bends light,
it bends radio waves.
It's um,
it,
it shouldn't be possible to communicate with a craft that has an envelope around
it that's distorting all forms of energy.
But they were apparently in contact with it
somehow or another suit through some unexplained way that they bother explaining
to you.
[inaudible] so this thing gets up.
It just does some very simple maneuvers.
Left,
right,
left,
goes down.
Um,
and did they discuss this with you?
I mean,
they said they wanted you to see it.
No,
they do.
They just want it now.
They,
they,
they didn't discuss anything with me.
It set at,
sat down.
We looked around for a bit and Barry's said,
let's go back.
We went back in the lab.
All we got to do is see it.
Um,
you know,
fast forward,
um,
to some months later,
uh,
I did have the test flight schedule of the craft.
Now they had times they had designated high performance tests.
This obviously wasn't one that was a high performance tests.
The uh,
high performance tests went,
goes above the mountain range and they do much more radical moves with the
thing.
Look,
this is a prized item and they're not doing anything like taking it out of the
atmosphere or flying around to other countries or anything like that.
This,
they just play with this thing right over the test site.
Um,
but they were doing some radical moves with it.
And since I had the test flight schedule,
statistically
the amount of traffic and the surrounding areas on the highway was lowest on
Wednesdays.
And that's why Dennis Dennis told us that,
uh,
all the test flights occurred only on Wednesdays because it'd be the least
chance at anyone would see what's going on.
And this was before the,
the government had expanded the forbidden territory around area 51 and papoose
lake and all that stuff.
Right?
Yeah.
I think that occurred after my story came out.
Then people started going up on the mountain tops and trying to look down into
there and they kind of freaked out and then did the land grab and pushed
everybody back.
But yeah,
that,
I think all of that occurred long after.
I'm sorry that I came out.
So
you were working there and while you're working there,
you're under this crazy schedule.
Forgive me for explaining your story,
but you,
uh,
would get these phone calls,
you would have to go to the,
to the airport at 11:00 PM and your wife started thinking you were having an
affair.
Yeah,
apparently.
So I'm now,
I did give my permission to have,
you know,
as,
as part of the,
you know,
security clearance process.
Um,
I gave her a written permission to have the phones monitored and things of that
sort.
So they weren't doing any covert stuff.
They,
um,
you know,
with any [inaudible] or which is civilian top secret clearance or military top
secret clearance,
they go talk to friends and you know,
play places you've been,
make sure you're not connected to foreign countries,
but you know,
monitoring your phone is nothing unusual.
However,
they insisted that,
you know,
you don't even talk to your loved one,
to your partner,
to your wife,
whatever about what's going on.
So she was essentially in the dark and didn't know the phone was being
monitored.
Well part of the security clearance is that not only do you not have any
connections to foreign countries in our,
in a maniac,
but you have to have a stable home life too.
Uh,
well she started having an affair with a flight instructor.
Now they were monitoring this on the phone and they knew it and I didn't.
So they stopped me coming in and their attitude at the time was,
um,
we need to see how this is going to play out and if Lazara is going to get a
little weird or anything.
So let's just,
you know,
hold them off from coming in and uh,
see what happens.
And they explained this to you.
What was happening?
Well after the fact.
Yeah.
Cause time kind of went on and there were guys that were following me around and
I started getting a little concerned going,
well jet or they booted me out of the project and if so,
they're not just going to let me hang out at home and go get a new job knowing
what I know.
So as time went on,
I started getting a little concerned and I took my closest friends and just kind
of got together and said,
hey,
remember that job I told you about?
This is what's going on.
And uh,
like you don't need to take my word for it Wednesday night,
we need to all go out here.
I want to show you what's going on.
So I took everybody and we went out to,
um,
members since I had the test flight schedule and went outside the base,
out into the desert.
And so everybody could see,
you know,
one of the high performance tests and uh,
left quite imprint on everybody.
So they knew I wasn't in this video is of these tests,
right?
Yeah.
But remember,
this isn't the,
it's in in the dark in the 80s or the big monster size cam quarter.
And you've got,
you know,
our bright light jumping around.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean we did video of it [inaudible] by today's standards.
It's,
but it's your video specifically available,
the video that you took.
Yeah.
Well George Knapp has it.
It's is it,
do you have no idea Jeremy?
I show clips of it in my film.
It's,
it's
online and someone did a deep analysis of it.
It was interesting,
uh,
to,
to take a look at how this microphone on to phrase this from your face.
Right.
Um,
you know,
to see how his video looks now.
But as far as video evidence,
I mean we're,
we are talking eighties campers and the most important thing is the human story
here.
Everybody that he took up there on three separate occasions,
they don't all like each other.
They don't all talk.
They all agree on one thing.
They saw something that night at the exact point in time and space that Bob was
our said,
remember this is 1750 and 70 miles south of here.
51 no one even knew really about area 51 we're talking papoose lake and they all
agree they saw something that night they had never seen before and they've never
seen sense right when he said it.
So that's one of like the six things where I'm like,
how did he know you can dismiss him?
I tried to dismiss it,
but somethings we can't get around and end.
There's about five or six of them.
How did he know about it?
If Jamie wants to find that video right now,
what would he look under?
Bob Czar Ufo,
s s four area 51 just kind of like that.
Uh,
so it's like the sub s for Ufo video.
Bob was our it guy does an analysis,
but you're,
and that analyzing these eighties videos,
right?
He,
from the very beginning,
Bob never said,
I have proof of my story and I'm gonna tell the world.
He said at the very beginning,
I cannot prove my story.
That's not why I'm telling this.
George Knapp convinced him to tell people and he lived through it and I didn't
believe it either until I talked with George.
Okay.
So you,
you film these,
this test flight one test fine and then you get caught.
Actually it was I think a third time because we went out there the first time
everybody saw it.
Everybody was amazed because it did some radical maneuvers.
And um,
you know,
everybody had a lot to say about it.
Maneuvers
seen,
I've seen the video.
It doesn't,
I don't think there's something we have now that does that.
No.
In terms of like a human piloted craft.
I mean,
I don't know obviously with [inaudible]
no,
it's,
it's impossible.
Nothing can move like that.
And remember we didn't start filming from the very beginning,
you know,
the core,
we were waiting for something,
you know,
to happen.
The craft took off and I came flying at us,
stop,
you know,
turned it around,
triangle flew back and then you know,
after did some,
you know,
amazing stuff to get the camera and the new we started filming so it doesn't
have all of it on there.
Just has some,
the way I describe it
to my friends and they said,
what does look like?
I said,
take a laser pointer and then have a wall and then move it around the wall.
Like you know how it moves around the wall.
It doesn't seem like it has anything to do with inertia or physics or it's not
impeded in any way by the atmosphere.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
You're essentially separated from reality.
As crazy as that sounds with being an in case it's an on gravitational envelope,
inertia is not going to affect it.
And you know,
this is uh,
this is how some of those recent sightings of Commander David Fravor,
I'm sure you've heard of the ticktack Ufo.
I mean he describes exactly that the thing operates exactly the way I was
describing.
That's why he was interested to talk to me.
Um,
but we saw this and you know,
on the way home it's like,
hey,
we got away with it.
We should try it again,
the next test flight date.
So this became a thing to do.
And I think it was on the,
the third time that we got caught.
I mean,
we started becoming a little careless.
I think we took a motor home out there,
you know,
I mean it was like this stupidest thing you could possibly tailgating.
Yeah,
it was ridiculous.
And um,
again,
you're in your 20s.
Yeah.
And you know what was funny was,
um,
we went out there and my friend Jean Huff and I were leaning on the front of the
vehicle and just for some reason we just started talking shit like,
uh,
well I hope they realize that,
I don't remember what we're saying,
but you know,
that it's something about attacking the base or something along those lines and
stealing the craft or something like that.
So I'm crazy.
And,
um,
then about 20 feet in front of us,
we see a little green light fall on the ground and roll to us.
And unbeknownst to us now it's pitch black.
You can't see your hand in front of your face.
There were a bunch of guards standing right out there and they had a night
vision scope where they were like from here to the wall looking at us,
listening to us.
And the guy dropped it in the scope rolled over to us and you could see the
green screen,
you know,
we turn the lights on and all these guys are there.
So it was uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
So we did incredibly stupid stuff and got caught as we should have.
Cause so when they catch you and they bring you in,
then what happens?
Well,
I went in for debriefing the following day I went to Indian springs air force
base,
which is kind of a defunct based that they used to use if the nuclear test site.
And this is when they brought out,
um,
the transcript of the phone call with my wife and,
you know,
they sat me down and we said,
when we meant to keep this secret,
we met,
you can't tell your friends.
Right.
You know,
and it just being sarcastic and trying to,
um,
and then they got real serious.
Uh,
but this is where they,
you know,
took the transcript out and were reading me what,
uh,
my wife and you know,
our friend we're talking about and uh,
I don't know.
It was a hard time.
So what happens from there?
Yeah.
What did they do with you?
Why don't they arrest you?
I don't think,
I don't know why.
I'm not sure they exactly,
they knew what to do,
but they did let me go that night and I went home.
And this is kind of when the most part started because you're realizing that
you're being monitored.
Yeah.
Now,
yeah.
Now I know not only am I being monitored,
but now I know I'm in trouble.
And,
uh,
it wasn't a short time after that that I contacted,
you know,
at that time the only investigative reporter I had heard of in Las Vegas was
George Knapp and,
um,
you know,
told him some of the story cause I had no idea what the hell was going to
happen.
And at that point,
so George Knapp tries to dissect your story,
tries to find holes in it,
tells it,
puts it online and makes everybody aware of it.
And that's how I found out about it.
Yeah.
To make a long story short hand,
w what happens yet to really make a long story short,
what happens from there on,
I mean,
do they contact you and say,
hey Bob,
it's probably a good idea if you shut up.
How
well they tried to label you as crazy was there.
Yeah,
there were a boy,
there were a lot of things that happened at,
you know,
between that point.
Um,
I'm leaving out a lot of stuff,
uh,
to fill in the story.
Uh,
we'd have to go back to Los Alamos and,
and
well,
I really don't want to talk about that.
The,
um,
top secret weapons stuff that you were working on?
No,
I'm talking about the one 15.
Yeah.
Well,
I dunno.
I have to think about how I had,
what is the problem
with this?
I don't want to get myself in,
don't more trouble by admitting something.
So,
um,
I just have to dance around a cup.
Well,
just during the filming of the movie,
people thought this movie's great by the way.
Thanks Joe.
And uh,
it's on Netflix right now for anyone who wants to check it out.
And if you're one of those people like me who,
um,
you know,
I've always loved the idea of Ufo shows.
I became extremely weary talking to people who are Ufo believers and Ufo
fanatics.
Cause there's so many of them that are full of shit and not just full of shit.
They're,
they're childish lead delirious,
like the way they talk about things.
I mean,
there's so many people that are,
that I'm in contact,
they reach me in the night and they explained to me what we're doing to the
ocean is wrong.
And like,
you know,
like,
okay,
this is one of the reasons I didn't want to do the show.
I'm sure
snow.
Yeah.
Well it's,
I mean,
it's no joke.
We've had people literally camp out on our front lawn and uh,
you know,
in some ways I can relate to some of these people.
You know,
maybe some of them did really have some kind of experience or saw something and
all their friends think they're crazy.
But Hey,
now there's this guy I heard on the radio and a l e t knows I'm not full of
Shit.
So I gotta talk to him.
And so most of the correspondents I get are people trying to get ahold of me
going by bu you gotta listen to me,
I'm,
I'm coming to talk to you.
you know,
I'm driving from Oklahoma or whatever and,
and,
but some of them are fucking
batshit crazy on there.
They're frightening.
There's a lot of schizophrenia that are involved in the conspiracy world.
So there's a lot of people that have real issues.
It would be a disservice to your audience to not say that.
We have to look at what's going on now and understand.
I've heard on your show a bunch of stuff about what's going on now and to not
really understand what's going on now.
You can't see Bob's story in the correct light after 30 years and at some point
we should just touch upon that.
Um,
the,
the biggest being that things like the ticktack Ufo case that came out,
I've heard people even on the show say,
oh,
there's a glitch in the radar.
That's a data port perspective.
You just don't know yet what's really going on.
Commander Fravor I was able to get the interview with him to talk to him way
before it became public.
I got that from him.
He sought other pilots sought,
this is a big thing that's going on right now.
They had more settings on the east coast recently.
Cubes with,
with spherical or is these are not aerodynamic and these are the people we trust
to defend us on nine 11 come out of favor protected Los Angeles on nine 11.
So we trust them,
but they're not trained observers.
Radar.
Individuals see these things and the big,
the big one,
just to throw it down so we can consider a story a little differently.
There's more depth to it.
The big one is the United States government has admitted that they had been
continuously studying the UFO phenomenon.
That program was called a tip advanced Eris or sorry,
uh,
was called all SAP.
That that's the mother program.
George Knapp got that out.
They,
they,
they announced through the New York Times about a tip,
but all SAP,
these acronyms,
all SAP advanced aerospace weapon systems,
applications program.
Who Cares?
That was the mother program,
so they've admitted we didn't stop sending your foes in 1969 with project blue
book.
We don't think it's crazy.
We're actually want to reverse engineer the technology.
That's why on your other show he said,
what's his AAV thing?
It's like they're making up another Ufo name.
We'll hold on.
There's a reason because in the documents,
the Dhi,
the dia documents that George Knapp released that everybody said was fake till
now they know is real.
They call them Aavs,
which is advanced aerospace vehicles.
People are getting the acronyms wrong.
So the reason for the terminology change is so that we can mimic what we're
reading in the dia documents.
People can look for that now.
So they changed the names to get people away from Ufo or UAP even like Hillary
Clinton said on air,
right.
So what are you talking about?
Hold guns.
Hillary Clinton informed the public on Jimmy Kimmel.
Oh Jimmy,
we don't call them Ufo is anymore.
We call them Uaa ps unidentified aerial phenomenon.
Right.
So she kind of was giving them,
the Clintons are very into the UFO topic.
Senator Reed,
you know,
he,
he's done a lot for the,
for the subject of study of it,
right?
So she informed the public so they could look for the right term.
So these terms are important because the dia in those documents,
they had calling them a views for quite some time now and they changed the name
to anomalous.
No,
that,
that's kind of a misnomer know.
So they always mess around with things,
but it's actually advanced.
Right.
But when they're describing it in the news,
they were calling an anomalous totally for you.
Totally.
And that's cool.
They were also saying anomalous aerospace threats,
a t right,
cause they want the sense of a threat.
Right.
So,
so my point is all of the,
if people don't know this now and they think this stuff is,
is fantasy,
this,
this part of it that we're studying it,
that we take it seriously,
we're spending money on it and that we're getting great data from,
from visual pilots to radar.
That's why we know it's aerospace.
They dropped from 80,000 feet.
But guess what?
That's the top scope of the spy.
One radar is 80,000 feet.
So the radar system they were using,
it was coming from above that.
So my point is this,
if you don't understand that this is happening,
you're just behind the curve because you don't have the information because of
the stigma that you're talking about.
I saw you get totally upset with the UFO topic.
I met you first when you get totally upset with you off a topic.
It's the people.
When,
when you,
when you're doing your whole this Mike,
I'm sorry man.
When you're,
when you're doing your show,
you know,
the Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
I could see how,
how frustrating is,
trust me,
I had been frustrated to how luckily my mentors George Knapp,
and he's taught me the pitfalls,
pitfalls as I went through it.
My whole point in this rant right here is just that we have to now look at Bob's
story.
But knowing the facts,
not someone saying it's a bird,
it's a plane.
It's a glitch there or not.
And so if you don't know that,
you just don't have the information yet.
Not yet.
Knowing the facts as we know them in 2019 not 19
absolutely.
And so what is,
he said that has come true.
He's totally unimpressed with it,
right?
What does he said?
This come true.
So I was like,
Bob,
they've announced gravity as a wave.
You were right,
man,
you're vindicated.
And he looks at me and he's like,
well,
if you think about it,
Jeremy,
I had like a 50 50 chance.
He was not very impressed,
right?
But under they announced gravity is a wave.
So they detected in a sense the attempted gravity waves.
Then who is they?
You might know more.
There's two black holes that were colliding and that's how they were able to
detect.
Yeah,
somebody's bill.
I don't know which group it was or what part of the government.
That's what Google's for.
Yeah,
what did,
but they,
um,
you know,
built a gigantic gravity wave detector and pretty much detected
did there such things as great as
first observation of gravitational waves.
It says it was in 2016.
Okay.
The first observation of gravitational waves was made on 14th of September,
2015 as announced by
the Lig Leo and Virgo collaborators on the 11th of February,
2016.
Previously,
gravitational waves had only been inferred indirectly via their effect on the
timing of pulse.
Ours in binary star systems downtown.
Um,
the way form connected by both Lig oh Ligo observatories mashed to predictions
of general relativity for gravity,
for a gravitational wave
feminine
emanating from the inward space,
trying to get this from the inward spiral and merger of a pair of black holes
around 36 and 29 solar masses.
And the subsequent ring down of the single resulting black hole.
Whoa.
Well that,
I mean he,
yeah,
no,
he was out in the 80s.
The predominant theory was gravity is produced by gravitons.
Okay.
Part of theoretic theoretical particles.
But um,
they're not,
there are waves.
They're not particles.
And so the thought is that the way we experienced gravity,
it's based on mass,
which is why the moon,
which is roughly one quarter of the size of the earth has won six of the earth's
gravity.
So there's some sort of a computation you can make based on mass.
Right?
And,
and remember we can observe the effects of gravity,
but we have no idea what it is.
All we can do is observe it and we can't make it.
The only way you can make gravity is just put more mass together and it's just a
product of gravity.
But if you can make a,
if you have a machine that makes gravity,
you can pretty much do anything.
You can affect time,
you can have force fields,
all that stuff that's in science fiction becomes reality.
If you have a machine that can make gravity,
and what we worked on in the desert was a machine that makes gravity,
I love your analogy of dropping off a small nuclear reactor to the Victorian
era.
I love that,
that analogy,
because back then that was impossible.
That was magic.
What you're talking about here,
the fact that they just discovered this four years ago,
that this is a wave and we are,
as much as we know and as impressed as we are,
as we should be with how much more technologically advanced we are than every
other creature on this planet.
We're still in many ways in the adolescence of technological and yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
If even adolescence
and when you're talking about this binary star system and Zeta ridiculous lie
and who knows how much longer were these things have been around than us,
who knows what their evolutionary cycles been?
Who knows what I mean?
We might be talking about something that's a million years more advanced than
us.
Yeah,
yeah.
It could easily be.
Now I'm not in,
believe it or not,
I'm not into Ufo hose.
I don't follow those stories or you know,
even to your experiences.
No,
I'm fascinated with the technology and I,
it really irks me.
Like every night I go to sleep that,
you know,
I don't,
that it was my own doing essentially,
that that prevented me from continuing on in the,
in the project.
I mean,
it's the,
that to be on that cutting edge of technology is so alluring to me.
Right.
But
yeah,
you know,
by the same token,
I don't really care that there's aliens are where they come from.
I mean the price is the technology and that's what I'm fascinated by.
But so I don't listen to Ufo stories and that sort of thing.
But George Knapp is,
um,
I mean he's the guy that as the context and tries to thread everything together.
And what he recently told me is he found,
I don't know,
it was either documentation or people that he spoke to.
It's at this,
the existence of this project,
the project that I was on,
it's something that they
seem to take out every eight or 10 years.
So that's a very specific memo.
And this is actually,
this is the first time I'll be very clear with people about it.
It's a big topic of conversation right now.
It's called the Wilson memo.
You can look it up.
Admiral Wilson met with a scientist who actually was featured in one of my
films.
Everybody has been debating whether or not this document,
I'll be conversation with a,
with an sitting out role at the time is a real document.
It's an actual conversation that happened in this document is where everybody
wants to know the world is going crazy right now on the UFO world.
I'll tell you straight up right now,
I'm in the position to know and it is a real document that it is real.
So the conversation you read in that,
that conversation was had,
I can't attest to everything.
You're not being very clear.
Sure,
please.
No problem.
So there was a document that is circulating right now that is really big.
It's going around everywhere.
People are asking,
what is this document?
It's called the Wilson memo is what?
How you can find it online.
There were the Wilson leak.
Third is Jimmy's.
Got It.
The Wilson memorandum use of human volunteers.
No,
that's not it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
Admiral Wilson meets with this scientist and they have this discussion,
oddly enough,
that special projects at Eg and g and I,
if I remembered the documents from 2001,
I'm telling everybody right now it's real and we'll see.
My history is pretty good with like say something's real or not right.
So here we go.
Document comes out,
they meet at Eg and g special projects in 1989 they stumble into a problem.
This happens,
they put the technology away and then they bring it back out and see if material
science has caught up and if they can make any progress.
So this document kind of talks about this process.
The big thing I get from it in a lot of it's vindicating to Bob and one of the
things that's vindicating besides the Eg and g thing is that private industry.
So this guy's an admiral and he says,
I sh I found out about your SAP,
your special access program.
I need to know about it.
And he's going to a private part of industry and he has denied access and he
says,
you know,
I should be running this program and they were able to deny him access.
So I think the takeaway here is check it out.
I'm telling you that that is an actual correct.
That is a leak.
Now everything's set in that document.
I don't know.
What are you talking about?
What is that in that document?
It's,
it's a,
between a scientist and an and admiral that are sitting and they're having a
meeting and they're talking about,
um,
the,
the search for the UFO subject,
the search to get special access program,
access to all of these different things like reverse engineering programs.
So in this document they talk about it.
Uh,
I believe that this document,
the,
the person that went was employed by Robert Bigelow.
You know,
one of the guys that has a couple of orbiting satellites and all that stuff.
Who's going to guy own skin Walker ranch?
No,
he's not.
He was the guy that owned skin walker.
Yeah,
he used to own it.
There's a new owner and I,
I interviewed him for my other film,
but there's a new owner and you'll be hearing a lot more about that soon.
But uh,
like it'll just,
there's,
there's stuff that you'll be hearing about skin walker ranch in cause there's a
new owner.
Anyway,
the whole point of this,
you know,
insertion here is just that,
that document kind of validates a lot of this idea.
Bob Just said that they make a little progress then they can't go anywhere.
They tuck it away and then they bring it back out,
you know,
10 years later and start working on it.
What is the limiting factor?
I think Bob should speak on this,
but it's the material science.
Yeah.
That's really where physics is.
So I can,
I can see them doing that.
I mean,
I didn't have any,
uh,
information on that,
but I think what,
you know,
George uncovered is probably accurate that,
uh,
you know,
we try and do what we can and once we reach a roadblock on,
we really can't figure it out.
It's just frigging wait,
put the thing away,
wait for science to catch up.
And,
you know,
a decade later,
let's take the project out again and see,
all right,
now where can we go?
But there's gotta be someone who remains informed.
Right?
Oh yeah.
You've got your scientists like you and bury you got your people that you
compartmentalize.
You got these people working on this.
There has to be some people that know everything.
You've got security and then someone's going to be in the outside saying,
hey,
we need people to guard this building.
Don't let anybody in for 10 years.
Yeah.
I think a lot of that is private industry and I think that's how they keep it.
I think that's how they literally,
because the government is just so leaky.
I think that's kind of what that is.
That's what the document kind of proves you just articulated that,
that um,
it is in control of private industry.
What private industry,
some aerospace company something.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
they wouldn't,
the guy with the admiral wouldn't name it in the car.
Right.
In the conversation.
Yeah.
So they still have these things supposedly,
I would guess,
I mean,
I don't have any information
asked anyone that has any inkling of any idea of where they'd got them or how
they got them
now.
But um,
something must have been said to me,
um,
from Barry and,
but I,
I,
it was just too long ago and I,
I can't quite remember what it said,
but it,
it just left a seed in my mind.
I think at least one of them was part of an archeological dig.
So it's old something that one,
at least one of them is old.
I don't know if it was the one I worked on,
but I remember something to do with an archeological deg.
Whoa.
So that's a,
that means it's not just old.
It's ancient.
That'd be a great Steven Spielberg movie.
Yeah.
All right.
That's all of it would when he said that for the first time.
That's a freak out right there.
And just a couple of dudes with some brushes looking for a tie,
ran a source,
rex bone and metal.
And when did they find it?
You know that they have nine of them.
Well,
and how could we have not heard about that?
What about the guys with the brushes?
How could you uncover something like that?
Joe's newspaper at home does,
I mean they set it on that first day.
Oh,
you mean the Roswell daily record when you told me,
yeah,
I have a cover.
What does this here,
Jamie is the document,
but I had to do some digging to find it.
Yeah,
it's just kind of,
yeah,
so this is where they meet at Eg and g and this is Admiral Wilson and there's a
lot more coming out.
Now.
I want to be clear.
George didn't put this out,
he didn't leak this out to anybody.
This is,
I can tell you how I courted this,
this conversation.
So this was an employee of at the time,
Robert Bigelow,
and this is in 2002,
right?
Do you remember when he had that government contract called [inaudible]?
The world all knows about now.
And he had nits that studied the ranch that 22 million.
Everybody is saying it was for a tip.
Um,
advanced airspace threat identification program.
The $22 million was for all SAP that was pushed through through Congress three
congressmen,
right.
And astronaut.
It was pushed through and that's what that $22 million,
by the way,
they spend more money on Viagra every year.
Then they do study in Ufos.
If it was just this program,
which I think is funny,
it'll be probably in the middle of have more money.
They probably do that.
You never know how it seeds into population.
But Anyway,
uh,
this program,
this is what was the mother program.
So it,
it got the 22 million and really it was to study skin Walker ranch.
Oddly enough,
that 22 lane all was inspired by the phenomenon.
They were seeing it skin walker ranch because the scientists,
they're seeing vehicles come through like a space in the sky.
We went there,
I went through,
yeah,
you interviewed me.
A bunch of people that seem full of shit,
but a couple of them,
but this very,
very interesting.
Totally theirs.
But if you look,
I spent a lot of time in the area.
I'm not talking about those stories.
I'm saying there were scientists hired by the government right through big low
to study the ranch because they thought it was important and you know,
whatever,
whatever the point is that 22 million was to study that.
Then we have a tip which is like an auxiliary kind of program of military
settings like commander flavors and that sort of thing.
This document is just one of those things that has now come forward that um,
through the big low studies,
it was government funded and then it was personally funded and then government
funded.
Um,
it's just one of those things that kind of shakes you because you've got this
military guy can't get
access because of the private industry that's holding these non-terrestrial
materials.
They can't study it.
So that's the,
the claim right now.
Give it some time.
Let people dig more into this.
It's fascinating man.
So you are essentially,
you're,
you're kicked out,
right?
You're,
you're out of this program.
You can't work with these crafts anymore.
And do they give you any threats?
Do they tell you what you have to do from here on out?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean the way it ended was,
um,
I told George Knapp all this stuff and um,
you know,
he said,
well,
let's just get it on tape.
Should something happen.
At least we have a record of it.
And um,
I don't remember what the impetus was,
but um,
at some point George wanted to air it and he said,
you know,
you make the call on it and look,
if at any point you change your mind,
uh,
we won't air it.
And it came down to the day where George wants to put her on the five o'clock
news.
You said eight,
this is important stuff.
People have to know about it.
And I thought it was too,
either.
It's kind of a crime.
I know you've got to keep the technology secret,
but you can't not tell everybody that this stuff is going on,
that we have,
you know,
actual hardware from another civilization.
It's a big fucking deal.
You know,
probably the biggest one there ever was.
And,
um,
George said,
you know,
today's the day we got her,
put her down the news,
there's something to that effect.
And when it came right down to the time to air it,
I changed my mind and I said,
we're not doing it.
And that's what turned into the famous wrestling match between me and George
trying to get the tape.
But he won because it was a bigger guy.
So you actually physically wrestled?
Well,
I think it was more of a pulling match.
We were,
I don't think we ever hit the ground,
but uh,
he got the tape,
you put it in the player and boom,
five o'clock news was on.
And then,
um,
I got a call after that and then they said it was from Dennis.
He said,
do you have any idea what we're going to do to you now?
Any hung up the phone?
That was the last communication I had with them.
And what has happened to you since then
after that?
Um,
a lot of people I have known,
um,
either were audited by the IRS.
People had anybody I know that had clearances that worked in secure programs,
had the clearance as Paul's,
one of them,
a friend that one of mine that Jeremy knows he's on camera with me soon,
he'll tell the story now that he's out of work up there.
He was working up at the Tonopah tests range waiting for his clearance to come
through.
And you know,
they,
they pulled that it would,
it became,
it's like if they can get the person that's involved,
they just create a problem for everybody that's around them.
And so mean the way it turns out,
it hurt a lot of people's lives that,
uh,
I was connected to.
And that's an effective way of shutting someone up.
So I feel that by coming forward and going public,
they couldn't just snuff you out.
That was,
I mean,
that's what I was told.
And George and everybody,
you know,
said that you can't,
oh,
it's an uncertainty.
It's public.
There's,
you know,
no one will touch you.
And I,
I,
you know,
I fell for it,
um,
and I,
I just wish you didn't.
Yeah.
Sometimes.
Sometimes when it's,
it's overstress and people were camping on your lawn.
Yeah,
but it's a,
this is gonna make things worse doing this.
No,
this is going to make things better.
Trying to tell him,
how is this gonna make things right?
Well,
because you're getting a real chance to explain yourself in a way that's going
to make people who are not only work in the government,
people that are police officers and firefighters and first responders and
doctors and scientists,
they're going to emphasize,
emphasize,
empathize,
and n empathize with
what it must be like to be a person like you in your 20s who gets thrust into
this world unknowingly and confronted with one of the most,
if not the most important discovery in the history of human beings.
The big question,
are we alone?
It's the number one question.
There's two questions,
right?
What happens when we die and are we alone?
Those are the two big questions,
right?
And if we're not alone and someone knows we're not alone,
and these some people who know we're not alone or these bungling sort of,
even if they weren't,
it's a crime that they're not telling the rest of us.
What do you mean?
I don't mean bundling in terms of they're incompetent.
I mean,
they can't be competent.
It seems to me to what you're describing,
that no one can be competent with this technology,
like the victory Victorian era scholars analyzing some sort of a nuclear
reactor.
There's,
there's no way.
Why do you think the are,
why do you think they're not telling us?
Let's just make an assumption that this is true right now.
Why do you think that they're not telling us that our government doesn't tell us
what's your best?
Well,
let me put it into you.
What would you do if I'm the president,
okay.
And I get this information,
what do I do with this?
What do I do with this?
There's something that we don't know.
There's something we don't understand.
There's some thing that came from another world we got,
it's tucked away in the mountains.
And,
uh,
I just want you guys to know about it.
Hey,
sleep tight.
Hey American Natto is on tonight.
Who Do you think's going to win?
Yeah.
Who's going to win?
America's got talent.
That data.
So one is uncertainty and the other one is what Bob and I've talked about a lot.
Absolutely not knowing what to tell people because you don't really understand
it yourself.
Even though you've got,
what do you say?
You as you want to run a government,
you want to get people to pay their tax,
but there's something else.
Yeah.
When you say you have these objects,
fine with impunity,
right?
And yet,
but you have someone else.
Well not only that,
what can you say?
Like how do you really know?
I think it's mainly the technology.
They just want to keep the technology.
So you have great,
because there's,
yeah,
whoever gets this,
there was this dude,
you,
you control the,
where you,
because you literally become invincible.
Once you master the technology,
you can't,
you cannot penetrate afield like that.
So I imagine that's,
I know it's all science fiction,
but science fiction turns into science fact.
If you have real force fields around aircraft and battleships,
you,
you win,
you can force your will upon anybody.
And uh,
like I said,
there's so much more to this story.
When I was first there,
um,
there were Russian scientists at us for that was,
this was early on in the project.
So this was before operation paperclip became public as well.
Right.
I would imagine that was,
I don't know what the dates are.
When was,
when did that was [inaudible] 98 I think 98 yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know the dates on it be roughly 10 years later operation paperclip
becomes freedom of Information Act.
We said that Russia,
not Germany,
he's never at Russian scientists.
Yeah.
But I mean Russian scientists,
a lot of them came from Germany.
A lot of those littles rocket scientists that work with NASA,
they all came from Nazi scientists.
Got It.
So some Russians got some of them.
I just know then at some point there was intense cooperation with Russia even
exchanging some ideas on nuclear weapons and you know,
emp tests and like things we would never have discussed with them.
But at the same time it was in the late eighties.
They were involved in actually in the area at as far with us and got to
communicate with these guys.
Or you saw them?
No,
I knew they were there.
Barry Barry would talk about the comedies that were there,
the comedy and the counties.
And that was back when they were the commies.
Yeah,
they were real economies.
Um,
and um,
at some point it wasn't our group,
but at some point there was a big discovery made and this did not happen when I
was there.
It happened in between my trips to there.
And after that,
apparently they decided it was just too cool to share with anybody in.
The Russians were never allowed back on the base after that.
But you don't know what the discovery?
No,
no.
Like I said,
it wasn't my group.
So one of the other groups really found out something,
but the,
you know,
in typical American fashion it was that.
All right,
this is ours.
You guys get the hell out of here.
Was there any inkling that any other government had something similar?
No,
not nothing that I had heard.
So that was the thing that always freaked me out was why if,
if something was so superior to human beings,
almost like visiting an ant colony,
like why would you go to the Queen?
I don't give a fuck who the queen is.
I'm a human.
I'm so superior to ants.
I don't care who you have running your hive,
I'm just going to study it.
I think it's who got it,
who got it.
Look at the,
you know,
rocket technology in Germany,
but they got nine of them.
Yeah,
that doesn't make sense to me either.
So they were either in the same area or you know,
one had clues to where others were.
I mean,
I don't know you,
you,
you have to fill that in there,
but you're right.
I mean nine of them,
that's a,
it's a a big dig.
If it was archaeological.
Well,
one of the more,
more
recent,
the recent sightings,
these discussions that have been coming out recently from air force pilots and
Navy pilots,
they've been talking about things happening in the ocean and that that's
something go literally goes into the water or something may be below the surface
about 2004 tic TAC Nimitz case.
So that's when George Knapp and I broke on the radio twice before the New York
Times said no,
this one really well the commander favor those pilots.
There was a disturbance on the surface of the water come out of favor visually
saw what looked like similar to a cross some object.
So it's like as if you have some that coral under the water and you've got,
it's breaking over.
The tic tac is doing this crazy maneuver that defies,
it's a gravity propelled says they saw it in the sky before this on the water,
right?
Yeah.
So there was um,
there were radar that was picking this,
these things come down from 80,000 feet drop in 50 feet in less than a second.
This is it,
Jamie.
What is it?
This is actually on the news today.
There is a brief.
So a lot of people get this confused about this one that either,
so that is called the gimbal.
So there's three videos released by the Pentagon that are all actual and keep
the volume off.
Okay.
I,
I would,
I would really just pay attention to the source video.
So you've got the tic TAC,
which is this object that commander Fravor saw another pilot filmed it with a
fleer pod and it goes to,
but this one you see is really important to Bob Story.
The gimbal craft.
It's been recently analyzed.
It's flir.
Not only does it,
it's definitive that it's not a conventional anything by the bites movements,
but there's a pocket of cold air around a propulsion source.
So this object,
by the way,
sat stationary,
um,
for days,
if not weeks,
it sat stationary.
You'll,
they founded 11 hours later and they were saying there's no way this thing using
that kind of energy to go that fast could just hover over the amount of time.
And by the way,
you're seeing a very small part of what happened that day.
This object was not alone.
And so hopefully that information comes out and we can,
I mean,
I wish we had video of it.
I'm sure we'd all want to see it,
but that's called the gimbal.
That was east coast,
right?
2015 west coast 2004 was the tic TAC.
The disturbance on the water commander fravor believes there was something under
that water that was causing that disturbance when the tic tac was coming around
to doing it with inside the,
the people that are studying this,
they're thinking maybe the tic TAC system was causing the disturbance,
but the u s o and identified submerged object that,
that he visually saw.
The whole interesting thing about that is I want love Bob to describe it as why
it doesn't matter if these craft or in space air or water.
Why doesn't it matter?
I love when he talks about this shit.
Well,
first of all,
commander
fravor was the f 18 pilot off the Nimitz that was sent out to find out what this
stuff is.
But,
uh,
and it wasn't just I got a chance to talk to him recently and it wasn't just a
radar image.
I mean commander fravor had eyes on it for over five minutes watching this thing
as for other pilots did.
So it wasn't a radar Blippar anything.
I mean these guys were watching this thing,
but um,
you know,
one of the things I think in the gimbal video,
the way the craft that we worked on flies is it doesn't fly like a conventional
aircraft does and it doesn't fly like a flying saucer winter in the 1950s movie.
It flies belly first.
I mean it may set down conventionally,
but it always rotates.
It does a role maneuver,
puts its belly towards the target and then moves away at high speed
car flying with the wheels forward.
Right,
right.
I mean,
it may lift it land on the wheels,
but at some point when it wants to leave slips up,
flips up,
points the wheels were at,
wants to go and takes off and the gimble video,
you can see the craft do the role maneuver and uh,
it's really interesting.
It behaves exactly like the craft that I work
don't so much like we have different shaped air crafts and fighter jets and
cars.
They probably have different shapes of these objects that operate under similar
principles.
Right?
But they all have the same power source,
all the same power source.
And we're also dealing with,
if you think about the laws of technological progression,
you know,
you think of Moore's law and you think of how things accelerate.
You've got to think that if this civilization is who knows how many years more
advanced than we are if not even years.
I mean,
I mean we're thinking about in terms of conventional terms,
right?
The way,
the way we look at the world than me,
they meet.
They might be just superior in terms of their intellect.
They've got to be maybe,
maybe we don't know.
Well the only reason I I say that is because look,
everyone doesn't necessarily start at a steam engine and go to an internal
combustion engine and then,
you know,
electric power,
nuclear power and go up the ladder that we can lean on.
Um,
you know,
the binary,
if the stuff is true about the origin and the binary star system and they have
heavier elements that we don't have and this element stable element one 15 is a
naturally occurring material.
Maybe that's the first thing they started experimenting with and the version of
their steam engine,
their first product was something that operated like this and actually when they
came to earth to look around or you know,
whatever,
they were amazed at the stuff we were doing.
These guys burned stuff and squirt,
squirted out the back to go forward.
So,
um,
right.
You know who says they follow any kind of normal progression like that?
My,
my thought was if you went back
to the 14 hundreds and then you went from 1400 to 1500,
you're not going to see that much of a difference technologically.
Right?
If you go from 2000 to 3000,
I assume there's going to be a radical change,
right?
Well,
the,
yeah,
the Delta,
their rate of change is,
is magnificently higher than it used to be.
Right?
So if you think about what they had in 1988 and you think about what they
probably have in 2019 just logically,
it seems like they would advance.
I would think so.
The only question is like are they living,
is that a living thing in terms of like a biological thing or are they some sort
of an artificially created creation like we are working on right now?
I mean we're in the middle of working on artificial reality,
artificial being sent the and beings artificial intelligence.
There's constant new silicon based life forms that they're essentially trying to
create Boston dinette or was it Boston Dynamics of the company?
[inaudible]
robots.
Yeah.
You can make machines out of flesh or cybernetic organism.
It's just that,
you know,
that's what a lot of people think.
Those like gray things are.
You know that people called the grays?
Yeah.
It's like they were like their machines rented from flash.
So what you're saying is like,
no,
no synthetic,
they don't even need to be,
you know,
machines.
Well they seem to have no sex organs.
So whether described by people that have had interactions with them,
assuming these people aren't liars or crazy or whatever,
right?
They have no sex organs and that they don't seem to have any muscle that just
almost like a frame and they have enormous heads.
I mean if you look at
Australia pythagoreous or depictions of ancient hominids and then you go to
human beings,
one of the things you see is bigger heads and weaker bodies.
Well you see some clear progression of evolution to where or something like
that.
I would lean towards a synthetic organism because it looks like it was made for
a specific tasks.
There's no reproductive organs.
So I mean that almost kind of leaves out any kind of,
you know,
physical evolution.
Right?
But that's also our bottleneck,
right?
Our bottleneck is our biological imperative.
The need to breed emotions,
fear,
anxiety,
all these different things that exist in order to force us into making sure we
reproduce.
I mean,
that's essentially what it is.
A human reward systems that aren't necessary once they can figure out a way to
make some sort of sentience,
artificial life.
So I'm sort of thing that doesn't have these biological limitations that we
have.
By the way,
these craft,
all these different kinds of been reported because it was confusing.
I always thought of flying saucers.
What I heard Bob was our talk about flying saucer.
Right?
But if you look back in history,
people have always reported the weirdest shapes.
Like none of them are alike.
You know there,
there are the saucers but you've got cigar shaped.
You got,
you know,
the top hat shaped you,
you have orbs.
Why?
Maybe they're serving different,
they're doing different
things.
Like we'd use different tools and I want to be clear,
the reason I know that memo is,
is real is because I spend a lot of time with doctor Edgar.
Mitchell is sixth man to walk on the Moon,
last guy to film him before he died.
Right?
That's how I know.
I don't want any journalists thinking I got it from anywhere else.
I know because of Dr. Mitchell and he said the same thing.
Maybe these things are performing different tasks,
you know,
seen.
If you,
if you think about what an alien is in terms of our are the sort of iconic image
of an alien,
like the Steven Spielberg close encounters of the third time,
the third kind alien,
they seem like what we'd assume a human being would eventually become.
Right?
And if these things are tiny,
human beings are smaller than they've ever been before,
they're weaker than they've ever been before.
And there seems to be a trend in that direction.
And this trend seems to be amplified by our technological progression.
There are a lack of need for muscle strength and our lack of need for violence.
And we're moving in a society to try to get away from all the things that we
think are a bore and about human beings and the terrible behaviors that we have.
If we one day do give birth to some sort of an artificial being like Marshall
McLuhan's a quote,
we are the sex organs of the machine world.
You know that one day we buy this.
Yeah,
McLuhan was brilliant and that that quote has always been one of my favorites
because,
okay,
what are we doing when we're constantly technologically innovating?
We're constantly looking for faster cars,
better computers,
bigger screens,
faster,
more resolution,
more pixels,
more this,
more that,
higher bandwidth,
five g,
10 G,
right?
What are we doing?
We're moving into this in this.
If you just follow it objectively,
stay,
stand back,
don't attach yourself or your civilization,
your culture to it,
and look at what it is.
We're moving it 100% towards technological innovation.
If you looked at this species from afar,
and if you weren't a part of it,
you'd say,
well,
what does this species do?
Oh,
they make things.
They make things better.
Every year.
Beehives,
the same fucking thing that you see 10 years ago,
you'd go by cob high.
It's amazing,
it's cool,
but they're the same fucking thing.
They figured out how to do it.
They make a beehive,
right?
We don't do that.
We make better things.
What would you constantly,
and at some point I think that technology is going to fuse with us.
Yes,
we're going to become,
it's already happening.
Eli Musk talked about it on my podcast that we are sideboards.
You just carry it in your pocket.
It's a phone.
It answers any question you want.
You can talk to it.
It'll give you the answers,
the answers instantaneously.
It navigates you.
It has all your phone numbers in it.
It has all your contacts.
You can get ahold of people,
people listening to you through it.
It's connecting us in ways,
even in voluntarily haptics,
that kind of,
yeah.
It's also getting on your wrist.
How many people have iWatches a apple watches the rest.
Right,
and that's only because we can't integrate them yet.
But you didn't know that point is 100% yeah.
I didn't joke about it last night,
but I have a bit about it,
but I do about the integration between humans and technology.
That's what would you do if you are hyper intelligence,
right?
Would you do the work yourself or would you create some cool things called like
humans to do it for you?
Would you create things that are cybernetic organisms to come in with machines
and do it for you?
If you a hyper intelligence that has kind of changed like you've described,
you'd probably create workers,
right?
Well,
that's a vast conspiracy theory is that,
I'm not talking about conspiracy,
but it is a kind of a conspiracy of asking you.
Well,
I mean I don't think it's necessarily that,
I mean you could look at it that way,
but that is the way a conspiracy theorist would look at it.
The way I would look at it as like,
there's obviously a progression going on,
a biological progression.
There's some sort of an integration with technology.
There's some sort of imperative this need for technological innovation.
It's in escapable.
Everyone has it and I think it's attached to materialism and some sort of a
strange way because so many people work so hard to get new things and like God,
that seems so illogical and preposterous and it makes people unhappy and
depressions on the rise,
but nobody seems to be able to stop it.
Like why is that?
Well,
maybe it's because we are the electronic caterpillars that give birth to the
butterfly.
Maybe that's what we're doing.
What our job is to do is to make some sort of a cocoon and we don't even know
we're doing it while we're doing it.
Do you think of Caterpillar as well?
Like,
Hey Caterpillar,
what are you doing man?
Just I'm doing my things,
my job.
I have to make it cool and then I'm going to come like a butterscotch natural
part of evolution.
It could be just supposed to do this.
Exactly.
Make the jump to some sort of mechanized,
right?
Yeah.
An orangutan that is a fishing with a spear.
Now they've figured out how to fish with spears.
There's uh,
there's um,
primatologists without somebody showing them how to fish.
No.
They've imitated human beings doing it and now they do it.
But they do it independently.
They're not trained orangutans.
They're wild rang.
Look at that
as a wild ride.
That's impressive.
Very impressive.
Well,
there's these primatologists I guess you would call them primatologist.
That's a term that's a great biologists,
biologists that believe that monkeys and chimps.
And some of the great apes are moving into the stone age that they've currently
entered the stone age.
Like they're not staying what they were a hundred thousand years ago or 500,000
years ago.
But they're actively using tools and they're experimenting with different,
different ways to use those tools.
And then they're making tools out of stone.
They're making tools out of sticks and they're,
they're using them.
Well,
this might just be what happens.
This might just be what happens.
I mean,
why,
why the fuck are we work so hard?
I mean,
I,
I was,
I was driving to La this morning.
I had a doctor's appointment,
so I was on the four oh five at eight in the morning.
Jesus Christ.
Like this is so crazy when you're in the four or five in La,
at eight o'clock in the morning,
you see literally a million cars.
And it's just everywhere you go,
it's people.
But,
and also I'm in a Tesla,
so I have it on autopilot.
So I'm there sitting,
I'm listening to a podcast.
I barely have my hand on the wheel.
I'm not touching shit.
This car's driving me along.
I'm not even doing anything.
I'm just,
I'm just hanging out.
It's so much less stressful by the way,
to do that that way.
So it encourages you to to innovate and encourages you to embrace this new
technology.
I got this giant screen.
It's showing me the navigation in front of me.
Oh,
be there five minutes early.
Excellent.
And I'm listening to a podcast wirelessly.
It's Bluetooth screen streaming from my phone and I pulled that podcast,
which came out today out of the fucking sky and I'm listening to it and I'm mall
comfortable and my nice little car just driving on my way to the doctor's
office.
This is irresistible stuff.
Different than your Walkman.
Yeah.
Irresistible scissor resistance.
Frighteningly irresistible.
It isn't frightening.
I mean,
if you were a monkey,
right?
If you were,
I'm an Australia [inaudible] would you go,
man,
I don't want to fucking be a person.
I live in a house.
That's bullshit.
I like just swinging around on trees.
I like running from Jaguars.
This is life guys.
Life is running from crocodiles.
It's not living in the fucking suburban committed.
Probably some that are like that.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think what,
when it comes,
we're going to embrace it.
We're going to embrace it the same way.
Embrace cell phones the same way.
Embrace television.
There's going to be a few holdouts.
I don't even know if an email Drew's man,
those,
there's a few and far between.
The good luck with that fuck face school moved to the woods.
Ted Kaczynski go live in a casket.
Ted Kaczynski was right.
This is something that I think about sometimes when I get really high that Ted
Kaczynski was a part of the Harvard LSD studies.
This has been proven Ted Kaczynski,
they cooked his fucking brain when he was at Harvard.
And then when he went over to Berkeley and became a professor,
his goal was to make enough money so that he could implement this program and
live in the woods and then write his manifesto and start killing people that
were involved in propagating technology.
He was expunged from the Harvard,
uh,
logs.
By the way,
this is something my friend just called me about.
So there's like this a private library and they used to print people's names
whenever they were part of a university and he was one of the handful of people
that were expunged from it.
I want to jump back to the one thing,
Joe,
I want to be really careful with that word conspiracy theorist.
What I was,
what I was saying to you is we terraform our earth,
right?
We tear from,
we change the environment,
we do all this innovation.
What is stopping us from thinking that that's not being done?
I'm not saying is,
I'm saying what's stopping us from thinking that that's being done on a much
bigger level.
On a cosmic level.
You mean like aliens coming down doing that to humans?
So I'm telling you that there is something here that there's a fact.
You know there's something,
there are craft.
They're here,
they're not ours,
they're here.
So the question is what is that about?
And I'm just looking at what we do with what you're describing with technology.
I think it's much more likely that the same way we observe chimps and we
observed that they are now in the stone age,
that they're observing us and that they're recognizing that there is a pattern,
that there is a,
there's a steps that happen.
I mean Carl Sagan talked about the different levels of civilization and then you
know that if we don't get past certain levels,
we're never going to reach this.
I mean,
we're in,
we're going to stay a type zero while we're in this warring,
polluting,
pillaging were awesome civilization.
It's like,
well,
me and we're awesome and a lot of ways,
you know,
in that way we're not.
Yeah,
we're,
we're children that have immense power that we didn't really,
the other thing is you're using the immense power that other people have
created,
right?
I mean even when you're driving a car,
you're stomping on the gas.
Like,
Whoa,
you didn't invent the fucking engine.
You didn't invent tires.
There's all these things that were in involved in the creation of this thing
that is really outside of your grasp of understanding,
but yet you have the ability to use it like a person with a gun.
I'm just going to bang,
Bang,
Bang people.
You don't,
you didn't invent a gun.
So like you've,
you've without the intellect to craft and engineer and,
and,
and manifest these creations.
You just have access to them because you have paper or you have bitcoin or
whatever the fuck you're using using a credit card.
Now you have almost no responsibility.
You just,
you could just flippantly use these things,
which is why we,
you know,
we were very childlike in our actions because we haven't had to earn the
responsibility.
We haven't had to earn these things that we've been able to have.
And you've only been able to have them because other people have innovated in,
spent ungodly amounts of time and effort and focus in the lab to create these
things.
And then they've all put them together.
And then what is the,
what's the reason to put them together to profit?
Well,
what's the reason of prop?
why are you doing this so you can buy more things?
Well,
what are we doing?
What are we doing?
We're making better things.
That's what we do.
That's all we do is make better thing.
Why the fuck do we need oil?
Why do we need oil?
Why can't we just burn wood and stay home?
Why can't we grow chickens and food in the backyard?
Why can't we do well,
we fucking can.
We certainly can.
People do do it,
but we decided to make that almost impossible.
Our preferred way of living,
it's this stuff.
Everyone into a very small area where no one grows anything other than weed.
This is what La is.
La is 20 million people with hard surfaces is as many hard surfaces you can boil
.
If you've got an acre backyard in La,
Holy Shit,
look at all that grain.
This is amazing.
Well,
no,
that's the fucking earth coming through this weird sort of creation that we've
put on top of the earth,
but the goal is to like New York City that there's none of it,
right?
You just got,
you've got central park and they just got human shit,
human stacked up,
no one's growing anything.
And then constant work,
everyone's up early,
go,
innovate progress,
make that money so you can buy more things and every year,
hey apple,
where's this fucking new phone?
As if your phone isn't good around phones taking pictures and videos and people
are calling you when you've got applications and tell you which way the wind's
blowing.
And it's not good enough.
A blink of an eye blink of an eye.
It's all gone though that,
you know,
like 10,000 years and the Hoover Dam goes or whatever,
Mt.
Rushmore disintegrate.
So it's amazing because we have created that and everything's trying to spring
up through that.
We keep it in maintenance down,
but we're,
we're a blink man.
Something hits.
But we don't think that way.
Well,
you know,
you think in terms of your own life,
right?
You think in terms of what you want and what you need right now.
You know,
it's,
we are in many ways this combination of this weird primitive ape like thing with
the ability to calculate and manipulate our world and our environment that makes
us wholly unique on top of that with existential angst and fear.
So what do you do with that with fucking Watertown,
with to antidepressants.
Give these fucking people some shit that keeps them moving,
whether worried about the future,
the trying to figure out what reality is.
If you're on a Goddamn convertible spaceships spinning a thousand miles an hour
hurling through infinity,
there's no meaning to this thing.
Just keep making shit,
keep making stuff and then one day they're going to be able to hit that switch
and this life will be born out of innovation and thinking and progress and
technology and more than likely,
it's probably going to be what we're seeing that these things are that you're,
you're,
you're observing.
I'm not observing them,
but yeah,
someone's,
are you implying that they're us?
I don't think they are us,
but I think they are.
What happens when things keep going?
[inaudible] that's not us.
Just like we're not monkeys,
right?
I'm not a chimp.
Oh,
that'd be cool.
Like they're from here is your idea.
No,
no,
no.
That,
this is what happens all over the universe,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
This is what happened.
Look,
here's the thing,
you know,
I went to see Brian Cox is um,
he has this amazing live show with Robin ins where they,
they,
they have these led screens,
he's huge screens with this high resolution depictions of the cosmos.
And one of the most mind blowing things was he has this large scale image of the
universe and it shows all the individual galaxies,
the universe,
and it just keeps moving through all these galaxies in three dimensions and it's
fucking incredible.
But what's stunning is the relative uniformity of it.
Even at,
you know,
I mean,
you're obviously looking at an incredibly small depiction of something that's
immensely large,
like a galaxy of hundreds of billions of stars.
You're seeing it as this little dot.
But this little dots that's flying through space surrounded by other little
darts with very similarly spaced distances between both through.
Yeah.
So Mike,
if we see uniformity in that form in terms of like the distance between galaxies
,
like so many galaxies is so it's so similar.
They might vary slightly and that slightly might be hundreds of millions of
light years.
Right?
But,
but,
but there's so much uniformity.
Why would we not assume that that uniformity exists pretty much everywhere and
that all these things that you're seeing that are so similar,
you do see binary star systems.
You do see single star systems like,
sorry,
but there's also some,
some speculation that earth and the,
that our solar system was one time was a binary star system,
right?
I mean that's one of the speculations about that,
that object that they find outside the Kuyper belt,
that the thing is 10 times larger than earth.
They think it might've been at one point in Thomas Star,
but this,
this uniformity that you see,
why wouldn't we think that that that has its same implications biologically,
that there's some sort of a biological uniformity and that this happens given
the right sets of circumstances.
You should be,
you should tell him to some of the stuff that you've read that you don't know is
true.
I mean,
if the stuff was true about the propulsion staff,
I mean anyway,
he,
well,
what have you read?
What did,
what did what you saw too,
you know,
what are you talking about?
Spill the beans.
Bob.
I got to poke the bear here.
That it get some more liquor in you.
The um,
well I mean the,
again,
the only thing I could verify was what I had my hands on.
Um,
they were,
you know,
there was talk of weapons systems that there were different projects,
projects like Galileo project sidekick was supposed to be weapon applications of
the craft.
Um,
project looking glass had to do with time,
any effects of time in the craft.
Now I don't think,
we're not talking about making a time machine like in science fiction,
but we're talking about,
you know,
small distortions,
intentional distortions of time and how that can be used,
you know,
as a,
uh,
not as,
well,
it was part of a weapon program.
How were you informed in this?
These again where there's just the small briefings that I read,
but again,
I don't really like to talk about those because I don't have any information on
him.
And it was just,
you know,
small briefing
because he told commander flavor that what he saw might've been a time dilation
and not,
well it could be both.
Just gravity affects time,
you know,
space time.
I'm sure you've heard of that.
And uh,
you know what,
what commander framers saw as he was in the f 18 approaching it,
he said it,
he described it as a,
a ping pong ball in a cup and shaking it back and forth.
It was moving that fast.
Now obviously if there's anything inside there,
it's going to be battered to hell.
But you know,
my point was was that well one of two things,
either there's a gravitational envelope in there which negates any inertia
effects or you are seeing through a gravity distortion field.
So you know,
just like you're looking at a hot highway and you see,
you know,
an optical distortion going through there.
Well,
the same thing happens in gravity and the craft may not actually be moving like
that.
It may just look like it because you're seeing,
you can only see it through the field.
So it may be making much more gentle moves.
I'm not saying that's it,
but it has to be one of the two
and the thing up 60 miles away.
They noticed it on radar 60 seconds after left commander favor,
but it was at his cap point,
which is the next point.
He was destined to go to 60 miles away and in 60 seconds on radar,
the same object ends up there.
So it's going a mile a second.
No,
they the,
I think the radar of just picked it up in 60 seconds.
Yeah,
I could've been there instantly,
but yeah,
we don't know the cycle.
Nobody knows that that's the whole thing is so it cycles like radar cycles
doesn't sweep determines,
yeah,
like the plainer
scans around it at random places to spy.
One does the really cool.
Yeah.
I didn't do the whole loop anymore.
Right.
And the point,
the point is though that the craft moved to his next location before he knew
where his next location was going to be.
Jesus.
And that's,
I mean,
that's well documented.
So that's a,
that's a pretty shocking piece of information.
What's fascinating to me too is that you were discussing this,
um,
the,
the way this react to work and that these things were not really connected.
No,
nothing is connected.
There's no wiring at all.
That freaks me the fuck out.
Charge your iPhone,
you know.
Well wireless.
Yeah.
I mean that's the,
that's a simple electromagnetic.
Yeah,
I know.
Again,
but that's just simple.
Electro Mandian magnetic induction enemy.
Tesla,
the scientist had this concept of,
right,
that's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
The word of saying he wanted to send wireless electricity through the sky and
Westinghouse was like,
get the fuck Outta here with that.
Like when anybody could just pull electricity out of this camp meter,
they couldn't talk in the car,
ride over and try to chill him out.
You know,
we're talking about Tesla now,
you know,
you couldn't be metered and now it all went down.
So it's funny you bring it up.
Yeah.
That,
that mean who knows what would have happened in terms of innovation?
Had he been allowed to go forward with that?
Well,
we probably wouldn't have computers.
You think?
Yeah,
I'm pretty positive.
I mean forget about microelectronics.
Well this is dumping huge amounts of electromagnetic energy in the air and yeah,
we'd be able to wirelessly turn on our lights,
but there'd be no radio communication.
The interference would be something we could,
would be overwhelming.
It would induce electric currents and anything with a small wire on it.
So integrated circuits,
transistors would be disintegrated before they were even,
you know,
tested for operation.
So it would destroy us up.
Yeah,
it would have stopped this dead.
We'd have,
it'd be great.
You can turn lighters on and heaters from all over the place with no wires,
but it would stop modern electronics and they slowly became dependent on it.
It would almost be like our dependence on fossil fuels,
although it's destructive,
it's very difficult for us to get off the nipple.
It would've changed the course of we developed,
which
is so interesting when you talk about if a civilization to the star system
didn't even start with fossil fuels.
They had one 15 naturally on their planet and they're like,
cool.
Antigravity is pretty awesome.
Well,
the fact that they didn't have important that that actually happened.
Yeah.
It might've been stopped in its tracks for a reason.
Whoa.
And
it's just,
it's,
I think it's incredibly difficult for us to imagine technological progression
under another timeline other than the one that we've experienced.
Yeah.
That's difficult.
If we imagine what this alien race must have been like and how,
I mean,
God,
just,
just to be able to see something like,
I mean obviously we've seen it in different life forms,
right?
Like we see the life of certain beetles in comparison to the life of certain
fish.
Very,
very different existence.
Very different life cycles.
Octopus.
Yeah.
I mean we see all these different variables in terms of biological entities on
earth,
but we don't see it in terms of technological innovation as we're the only one
that's intelligent that can innovate when we have intelligent creatures,
but they're in the ocean.
The only other thing that are like us or dolphins and orcas and whales and they
don't have the ability to manipulate their environment and subsequently because
they don't have the ability to manipulate their environment,
we put them in fish tanks and we were like,
get in the tank,
do some tricks.
Yup.
The only thing he saw in the craft,
if we are considering Bob's story,
the only thing that you,
he saw in the craft that he related to that looked like a human could make was
this honeycomb hatch.
And I always loved that because you're like obsessed with this thing that you
could recommend.
No,
the re yeah.
I only focus on that because it was the one thing that I understood how it
worked and it was,
it was the access to the level below and it was um,
well,
you know,
if you take a,
you have a six pack of beer and you take out the cardboard dividers,
set it on the table,
you can put a lot of pressure on the top.
But if you push it from the sides,
it collapses flat.
So it was something like that in a honeycomb shape that was essentially some
sort of sheet metal.
And you could walk on that in the upper layer.
But if you took the corner,
stuck your finger finger in and pushed it collapsed and Meda and entryway.
So I thought that was a really unique,
I'd never seen that before.
And it was the only thing in the crap that made absolute sense to me as it,
ah,
we can make that.
And all that is,
is a hatch.
Was there any discussion about the materials that were used to make the craft?
I'm sure there was,
but that was a metallurgy division has nothing to do with us.
So you never got a,
not even the slightest briefing.
I don't even know if it was a metal or it was ceramic.
It's a,
I think there's a fine line between the,
yeah.
Now one of the things that's happened to you that has allowed people to
discredit you was there's obviously been some sort of an effort to erase your
past.
Yeah.
Some sort of an a ref,
uh,
an effort to erase your education history,
your employment history at Los Alamos.
In fact,
the only way your employment history was proven at Los Alamos was someone got a
list of directory of the employees from the past and read into it and you were
on that list.
So it prove that you worked there,
even though people were trying to deny it and they were trying to use that as a
way to discredit you,
that you never did work at Los Alamos.
You weren't really the scientists.
What was,
what was that like to experience?
I mean,
of course we're talking about the 1980s,
the 1990s when you could get away with something like that.
Yeah.
I obviously there are a lot less,
uh,
allow US records on computers.
At that time it was still file cabinets and folders,
but uh,
yeah,
that was frightening.
That was one of the first things answered.
Yeah,
I think it's,
I think George Knapp was the first one that uncovered that.
I mean,
he saw my birth certificate disappear.
He,
um,
it disappeared.
Yeah.
It was no record of you being,
yeah,
there was,
there was no record of that.
There was
no record.
His mom tells me about that.
Like it was frightening for her for he's got a real family,
you know,
he's a real person.
That's frightening for her.
But even the Los Alamos thing really surprised me and that they were so adamant
that now this guy never worked here,
don't be ridiculous.
And George went back and forth,
you know,
for months.
I mean,
it was ridiculous.
But fortunately somebody came up with a 1982 phone book directory.
I mean,
and also,
uh,
originally I told you,
you know,
when I worked there,
I was on the front page of the paper,
so they were still able to archive,
you know,
break,
bring that back from the archives.
And you know,
Bob was our,
a physicist working here at Los Alamos,
so there was at least something there.
But,
uh,
somehow George came up with the phone directly
during the,
George didn't,
Bob took George with cameras into Los Alamos.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So we flew out there and I said,
look,
come on in,
I'll show you where I worked.
We'll go in,
we'll meet people.
And George went with me and you know,
they'll be inside that place.
Oh yeah.
And you know,
met people and you know,
and
it was also the place where they had the machine that was able to read the,
the size of your digits.
No,
no,
that was awesome.
That was s four that was asked for and explain that.
So now this was back in the 80s,
and this is back in the 80s.
Yeah.
Where when you discuss this,
people like this doesn't even exist.
Yeah.
Okay.
What was it?
It was a way,
you know,
this is before fingerprint scanners and you know,
and anything of anything,
any high resolution scanner that time.
So what it was was a device that a had a little picture of a hand on a glass
plate with pins in it so you could jam your hand in there and there was a bright
light above it and a sensor underneath.
And when you put your hand in there,
the light would turn on and it would measure the bones in your finger because
the light shown through your bones and apparently the length of the bones in
your fingers are extremely unique and easy to measure.
And they use that.
When you put your hands on there,
the light would turn on and your badge would pop out.
Oh there it is.
That's,
that's it.
And I tried to describe this to people and they said,
that is the most ridiculous thing we've ever heard.
And um,
I said,
hey,
that my badge came out of that thing.
I put my hand on it,
badge popped out.
And that's how I could open the doors and get into s four and um,
you know,
and everybody discredited that.
They said it was bullshit.
It was science fiction.
And Jeremy,
you found this,
I,
I found it through a good friend of mine named Tyler rogue away and he had some
good sources inside a very 52 where they also used these for the stealth program
right around that time.
So now I've got all these people that worked within who he knows said only if
you're in certain programs would we use this technology is kind of shit.
Actually they didn't keep it for very long,
the beginning of biometrics.
So I was able to reveal it in my film.
I kept my mouth shut until I showed it to Bob.
You know,
in the movie is the first time he saw it was how you see it in the documentary.
That's his genuine reaction.
I'm getting goosebumps.
That was a great idea that the way you did it.
Thank you man.
Because you know what?
Guess what I'm,
I'm actually trying to see if he's telling the truth.
That's how I started.
You know,
that's how we started.
So it was really cool to see that and that you get to see it.
His actual reaction has that been verified by other people?
Yeah.
So yeah.
So to me it has,
uh,
personally I get emails every day and people are telling me where these are used
and how they're used in a semi photos.
I got a lot of photos of identity mats now.
Well,
how they were used right there.
Not how they were used,
but yeah.
But uh,
I don't,
the most recent one was way more recent than I thought in another country,
but yeah,
that technology was used.
So what's so funny is,
um,
that this technology,
even in the area of 52 where they'd use them for Tona Paul,
one of the guys who will go on camera when he will do an interview with me,
he was a technician for one of these and any hated them because they were really
bad.
They always broke down and river.
And he was a technician forum that he won't tell me where if he worked at area
52.
So there's probably tone apoc.
It's very separated even on base.
But yeah,
so there was that.
Yeah.
There is your education record.
That was also like what happened with that?
The well,
that disappeared also,
you know,
that I,
I've,
I've never gone,
I've never gone anywhere for education.
I never attended any classes at cal tech.
I never attended anything at Mit.
You did attend classes in those places that I did attend classes and those
places.
Do you know anybody that you went to school with that?
Yes,
I do.
And have they verified that they went to school with you?
Well,
I gave Jeremy some names,
but yeah.
I,
the reason I don't say these names publicly is because every single time I
mentioned a name,
somebody gets in trouble to be course.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Um,
but what,
what is that experience
like seeing your birth certificate erased?
Seeing your employment is frightening.
It's,
it's absolutely fraught.
It's also the fueled that the debunkers use,
the so called air quotes skeptics.
I don't like the term skeptics.
I'm gonna say this publicly because I really only send this privately.
I think it's a sloppy,
lazy way to look at things,
to just be a skeptic.
[inaudible] those people can be objective and I think there's a lot of things
you should be skeptical of.
I think you should,
you should look at things and look at things from a hard line science
perspective.
You should be objective,
but the idea of skeptics,
the problem with that is you're always looking for things to be bullshit.
Yeah,
and I think that's dangerous because I think some things aren't bullshitting
information bias.
On the other end,
you're deciding to take a square thing and put it in a round hole no matter
what,
and I find a lot of them to be lazy,
a lot of them to be lazy thinkers because they're always putting it into that
box instead of going,
hmm,
instead of just separating their ego,
they're trying,
they're playing a game and the game is calling bullshit.
I want to call bullshit and I'm going to align up all these reasons why it's
bullshit and I'm going to ignore anything that might be contrary to that
definition.
Yeah,
that does.
Every time I'm thinking I'm going to catch him in something,
you know,
all along this process,
um,
I found doctor Crangle,
he came forward and said,
I was in security briefings with Bob Lasar are the physicist at Los Alamos.
He went on the record with me.
Now the other people I talked with,
why won't they go on the record with me?
Cause he's still working there.
So that,
that's the difference,
right?
What is the,
what can the public have,
right?
Or even if they're not working,
they're the,
you know,
they want to live their lives.
I mean,
obviously people have seen what's happened to you,
Mike Pin
After 30 years on them.
If you look at all the information on,
you know,
concerning my accounts,
that's,
that's verifiable.
It can't possibly be a bullshit story anymore.
It's really way past that point.
Yeah.
I mean that was my big pen is,
I mean,
how could I possibly know?
So Mike Big Pin was the guy that did the security clearances to go to the bay.
One of the guys that was used,
the guy that you work with,
he said he did.
Right.
And George Knapp.
George didn't believe him.
George put him through for polygraph tests.
Right.
He tried to see,
man,
this is a big risk.
It sounds interesting,
but let's see if he's telling the truth.
One of the things was Bob said there's a guy named Mike Figg.
Penny did security clearances for the base and that's a weird name.
It's a very specific,
for 30 years,
George found this guy in this weird department that he didn't even know it was
my big pin.
The guy wouldn't talk to me,
goes to them,
totally goes from for 30 years,
used Facebook and Google image match through his children.
I was able to find him after 30 years and I talked to him three times on the
phone.
He lives on the east coast.
He almost went on camera with me,
confirmed that he did security clearances for the base in 1989 confirmed.
He remembers Bob Lasar.
And what you don't know is there's a handwritten note that a friend of yours has
from Mike that I know I'm gonna give it to you later.
I don't,
but that is real.
That is actual.
So handwritten note that says what you know,
like this is new.
So when the eye,
when you're,
when they do security clearances,
they go through all your friends and finagle the offense.
Yeah.
So this is to Bob and I had people come to me for a friend of mine that's
serving and they are doing a security plans for him.
And even though I'm like the Ufo Guy,
uh,
they did,
you know,
the FBI come and visit my house and make sure that they talk about my friend and
they lift a little card.
And when my wife told him to get away because he didn't know who they were,
they left a little card.
It's super cute now.
Back then it was a handwritten note and his friend has it for him that you
haven't seen in,
Oh my God.
Two decades.
So if you're listening,
I don't know why I'm told is this card,
it's just a little handwritten note with Mike Figg pen signature card,
like a look,
a look,
a postcard,
like a piece of paper that he left on the door saying when Bob gets back or
whatever it says on it.
So it's just another little funny thing I found the guy,
he does the security clearances.
He admitted to me,
he did it and he admitted to me he was dodging George Knapp because when George
said his name on the,
on the,
on the news,
he dropped his fork into his steak or news potatoes or whatever and he's looking
at his wife.
He was in trouble.
His name is never supposed to be out there like it's just a security clearance
guy,
but you don't want national attention associated with anything Bob has to say.
But anyway,
this unique name Bob said for 30 years and the guy goes to George Knapp,
George could prove he existed.
He actually talked to me,
man,
he talked to me three times.
He almost went on camera with me.
It's just crazy.
What,
what do you,
what happens after 30 years?
You just get more info.
Well,
that's one of the reasons why when you and me and Jeremy and George Knapp had
that conversation on the phone.
Yeah.
I said,
I think what we can do with this podcast is important.
I really do.
I think it's important for people to hear this from you in a very clear,
just very concise way and if you examine all the information that you've said
today,
if you look at all the things that the detractors of said,
if you look at all of the new recent evidence that's coming out in all these
really high level people in the military and the government that are discussing
this,
it gives you far more credibility than you would have had in the 19 insurance
when this came out.
Yes.
You can't ignore his story just because you don't like it anymore.
That's why I thought it was important that you come out and refresh the world's
memory and let people know.
And like I said,
I've been,
man,
I want to say I'm a fan of yours,
but I guess I'm a fan of yours as a human being.
I'm a fan of yours,
but I've been following you for decades.
I've been following this story for decades.
I mean,
no kidding.
I have VHS
like a lot of the world has.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Well,
anybody that has any sort of a vested interest or just,
uh,
even a,
just a fascination with Ufo is as followed your story because there's no one
else.
There's no one else that comes for this.
Some guy who said,
I worked underground with the aliens,
they shot my hand off.
Like this is a bunch of like wacky dudes that let their underground is base as
they're shooting lasers through the earth's crust and move them,
had lightspeed.
There's a lot of those guys.
They seem schizophrenia.
They seem crazy.
They might even be disinformation agents.
They might be people that are designed to muddy the waters,
which for sure has happened.
He's coming forward then now it's amazing.
And by doing this,
what you're doing,
you're providing an opportunities for Bob to tell a story.
You know,
believe it or not,
he can tell his story.
It's amazing because more people will come forward now that are involved with
these projects.
They'll come forward to you to meet.
They're coming forward.
And so what you've done here is provide that opportunity if they need it.
And it's amazing.
I just want to say,
Bob,
don't come forward to,
no,
don't come forward to Bob.
Why were,
why were you fricking nauseous at the beginning of this?
Like so upset.
Why was your,
why did you have a Migraine?
Because that started off so hard and I got us in here like did this,
why are you asking them why?
Because obvious anxiety.
The guy's gone to 30 fucking years of being persecuted.
I just want to kiss his birth certificate.
I just want to hear,
I want to hear him say,
I want them to do is to say that you don't get it.
I step out.
Settle down.
Yeah.
Well I get it.
You were,
it was hard for you to get them here,
you know,
and I appreciate the US.
Yeah.
You know,
you didn't want more than that.
It really annoys me or the people that thing,
you know,
you guys just came up with the story to make a bunch of money or get a bunch of,
attention and that's a good point.
So let's please explain that you don't get any money out of this at all.
And I may,
I didn't even let you guys buy plane tickets for me to come out here.
Anything.
I mean,
anytime like when Jeremy,
uh,
pre previewed,
I guess the movie up in Michigan,
I mean they,
it brought in like a couple thousand dollars.
I made sure that $2,000 went to science programs at the local high schools.
There I dirty money,
I don't take touch.
I don't take any money from this stuff.
And as far as attention,
I hate fucking attention.
I don't like being on shows.
I just want to kind of hide in the corner and do my own thing.
So that's,
I got enough hugs when I was a kid.
Okay.
I don't need any attention.
So know that if,
if you,
if you think somehow we came up with this thing,
then you got to tell me why we did it.
Great job of making sure you have your bases covered in that regard,
that you haven't profited off of this.
And like you said,
that you have donated whatever money that came your way to science programs.
It's,
I mean,
it,
it doesn't make any sense any other way.
I mean,
what you're,
what I've got gotten out of here is what I thought I was going to get out of
here when I watched the documentary that you,
what you're saying makes sense.
It doesn't make sense that it's bullshit that happened exactly like I said it,
that Joe,
I believe you.
Um,
in closing,
is there anything else you'd like to say?
Okay.
No,
I can't think of anything other than really don't come and try to visit me.
Well.
Um,
I know that you have paid a huge personal cost to get this information out.
And I mean,
maybe you didn't understand what that cost would have been when you first
initially came forward with the story,
but over the past 30 years,
it's been immense.
It's been great.
And I just wanna thank you for that and thank you for all,
all these people that would not have gotten this information and would not have
really had this story any other way.
Oh,
thanks Joe.
Thank you.
And thank you,
Jeremy.
And one more time.
The documentary is available on Netflix right now.
Yeah,
it's called the Bob Lasar area 51 and flying saucers.
All right.
That's it folks tonight.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].